so ob der kram alles funktioniert ausschieben er muss da nicht eingeblendet werden ein stream
ja relativ früh 14 30 so frühe monka x monka s monka x monka monka giga monka mega monka s ja
schön dass so viele schon da sind was ist denn hier los warum seid ihr denn schon alle da dachte
normale leute müssen arbeiten um die uhrzeit ich ja eigentlich auch aber bei mir hat sich das ja
montags erledigt home office sehr gut ja man kann das ja fast schon als fortbuchung veranschlagen
hier urlaub auf hielt's gut man ja ja komm ich muss ich krieg schon weniger kohle da kann ich
wenigstens auch mal so tun als für als ist es das einzig wahre dass wir vier tage arbeit die
woche aber ich bin auch eher überzeugt von dass das das beste ist was man machen kann
du kannst das auch machen ihr kriegt in der schweiz so viel geld easy übrigens ich muss mal
kurz refreshen mein twitch zeigt außerdem chat nichts an keine zuschauer keine vorschau kein
sonst irgendwas das sagt vorlesung gammeln exzellent ein easy as fuck sagt die
licht aber ich verstehe man kann das man kann das falsch verstehen dass japanische text to speech
ist halt noch verbesserungswürdig aber ich meine man versteht verhältnismäßig gut kommt man jetzt
zum beispiel zum beispiel wo habe ich denn jetzt okay dass sie wieder übelst mies abgemischt dann
sich wieder nicht entscheiden welche lautstärke was haben soll exzellent also
flixcoder mein fall ist es auch nicht aber ich trinke kaum was das einzige was
ich trinke ab und zu mal zu weihnachten irgendwelche wein irgendwelche weine
oder was auch ganz da ist es bis whisky aber ich trinke ich so gut wie nix
trink nur exquisite sachen habt ihr schon windows 10 windows 10 20 h2 installiert ich
habe es ja noch nicht von mir ist noch 2004 bruchs mal linux starten weil wir brauchen
jetzt auf jeden fall linux vm gibt es was besonderes neues nein du kannst jetzt das
startmenü
also das einzige was wir hängen geblieben ist an neuigkeiten ist das jetzt im startmenü der
blaue der blaue hintergrund hinter icons weg ist dass das einzige was ich mir gemerkt habe
was neu ist an windows 2010 20 h2 das ist das einzige was ich mir gemerkt habe ich
meine dafür kann man auch schon mal ein halbes jahr brauchen jemand hier dieses
leben lassen das ist für mich ist halt einfach garbage ich kann ich nicht so lange
einfach ein bisschen tidiger beim
weser
so also erst mal die ganze krimi hier wegmachen aber es wird ausgeschaltet docker ipfs alles weg sehr gut also es gibt seit ungefähr einer woche gibt es jetzt vor allem die esx für Redbox zum arbeit.
Raspberry Pi. Das ist so ein Ding, wo Leute
seit Jahren danach gefragt haben
und, äh, was heißt gefragt?
Wo sich auch Leute, oh, oh Leute,
ich hab grad was ganz, ganz Kritisches gesehen.
Ich hab meine Kamera nicht,
nicht beschwert. Das heißt,
wenn die runterfällt, dann wird geleakt.
Monka Leak.
Das Risiko wollen wir da nicht
eingehen, deswegen muss ich die Kamera
beschweren.
Also das ist ja mein iPhone, von dem ich das streame.
So.
Ja, es gibt ja schon
andere Virtualisierungsmöglichkeiten,
was man auf dem Raspberry Pi machen kann.
Also man kann
jetzt mal anfangen mit
kleinen Sachen, was zwar keine richtige
Virtualisierung ist. Irgendwelche LXC,
LXD, Docker-Geschichten.
Dann kann man weitermachen mit KVM.
Dann gibt es jetzt Xen, seit neuestem,
auch für den Raspberry Pi.
Das ist die Citrix-Geschichte.
Oder Citrix,
oder Citrix, oder Zytrix.
Citrix, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig...
Wie spricht man das richtig aus?
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie man das richtig schreibt. So, oder?
Okay, wie spricht man das aus?
Wie, Aussprache.
Citrix, Zytrix.
Wie spricht man das besonders cool aus?
Zytrix.
Okay, okay, wie spricht man das aus?
How to pronounce Citrix...
Okay, okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal anhören.
Wir machen das die coolen Leute.
Emma saying.
Das ist wieder so ein Video.
Fünf Sekunden.
Fünf Sekunden ein Wort gesagt und erst mal 30.000 Intro.
Drei, drei, drei, drei Sekunden Intro.
Moment, die machen ernsthaft ein Video...
Moment, ist das jetzt ein Mensch oder ist das Text-to-Speech?
Das ist ein Mensch, oder?
Das ist ein Mensch.
Das ist schwer zu sagen, das könnte auch Text-to-Speech sein.
Emma saying.
Warum hat das so viel...
Citrix Systems, Citrix Systems.
Ja, wie oft...
Moment, wiederholen die das jetzt?
Weep Text-to-Speech...
Oh, das machen wir jetzt mal.
Da crasht es aber wieder, wenn ich das...
Das ist nämlich...
Das hat nämlich einen Bug und ich war bisher zu faul, das zu fixen.
Wenn man Text-to-Speech hinzufügen will...
Und ich glaube, man muss das...
Man muss das erste Mal hier umstellen.
Und jetzt geht das.
Citrix.
Okay, das hat mit der Realität überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Scheiße, das ist da komplett nebendran.
Citrix System.
Citrix, was?
Was?
Citrix Systems.
What?
Ich verstehe nichts, ich verstehe absolut gar nichts.
Citrix Systems.
Was ist das für ein Fehler, Alter?
Okay.
Wichtig, gut, dass wir das jetzt mal angehört haben.
Wie man das nicht ausspricht.
Gut, ähm...
Und jetzt mal die eigentliche Sache.
Ähm...
Was ich gerade sagen wollte, nochmal fertig, fertig, äh...
Also, es gibt ja, wie gesagt, ein paar Sachen von Raspberry Pi, was Virtualisierung angeht.
KVM.
Und da habe ich gesagt, Docker Gedöns, was keine wirkliche Virtualisierung ist, aber ist ja recht beliebt auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Ähm...
Dann kann man KVM machen.
Dann kann man neuerdings Xen machen.
Also diese Citrix...
Citrix...
Nee.
Citrix Systems kann man machen.
Und...
Jetzt neuerdings kann man auch, ähm...
Vor allem bei ESX machen.
Das ist ne Sache, wo seit Jahren schon danach gefragt wird.
Wenn ihr, wenn ihr mal sucht hier, Reddit, ESX, I, Pi, da gibt's Threads von 2006 oder 7 oder so.
Und, und, das wollen sie alle haben.
So.
Und da kam, war, gab's immer als Antwort, lohnt sich doch überhaupt nicht.
Gibt es eine Alternative zu VML Converter?
Kein Schimmer.
Ich, ich kenn mich mit VML nicht wirklich gut aus.
Ähm...
So, und da, da war, kam als Antwort immer, ich verfolge ja so ein bisschen auch so die ganzen, äh, Reddit, Subreddits von Sachen, die ich nicht unbedingt jetzt jeden Tag, jeden Tag verwende.
So, die Standardantwort ist immer da drauf, so nach dem Wort, warum will man sowas machen?
Ja, genau.
Sowas wie der Chillfreak fragt.
Und die, ich, ich finde das ist ne berechtigte Frage, weil mir fällt auch nix dazu ein, was man wirklich großartig damit machen will.
Aber...
Das ist wahrscheinlich genauso wie, warum will man nen Kubernetes-Gedöns laufen lassen auf seinem Raspberry?
Raspberry Pi.
Erstens, weil's geht.
Und zweitens, weil man dabei was lernt.
Ich glaube, ne Raspberry Pi ist ne super Übungs-MG, Umgebung, äh, wo man sich das Ganze daheim angucken kann, ohne dass man da jetzt größere Investitionen tätigen muss, ja.
Ich glaub, man kann sich, man kann sich, glaub ich, mittlerweile ESX auch nested, virtualisiert machen auf nem VML Workstation, glaub das geht auch.
Ja.
Äh, kurz...
Guckste, was ist MG-Monka-S?
Was, äh, möchtest du uns mitteilen?
Also, ich glaube, das am ehesten ist noch, dass man das eben lernt damit.
Ja.
Äh, dazu kommt ja auch, dass das nicht nur nen Build von Raspberry Pi ist, man kann das auch auf anderen ARM-Sachen installieren.
Aber ganz viele Leute, wie gesagt, wenn man Reddit, äh, verfolgt, haben sich das seit Jahren gewünscht.
So.
Die Sache ist die, ich hab kein, ich hab kein 8 Gigabyte.
ESX.
Äh, kein 8 Gigabyte Pi.
Ich hab nen 4 Gigabyte Pi.
4.
Das war damals der größte, den's gibt.
Aber die sagen, man braucht nen 4 oder nen 8 Gigabit-Modell.
Also, probieren wir, probieren wir aus.
Äh, was ich nicht so ganz mitverstehe, was die uns hier sagen wollen, was Data Center Near Edge und Far Edge ist.
Das ist bestimmt VMware, äh, Speak, den man als Normalsterblicher nicht versteht, außer man ist für VMware Certified Architect oder irgendwie so gedöhnt.
Was auch immer Near Edge und Far Edge sein soll.
Oder Data Center, kannst du dir beim nächsten Mal was vorstellen.
Stonks Gelaber, ja, hört sich echt so an.
So, jetzt müssen wir die ganzen Karten erstmal downloaden.
Ich hab noch nichts gemacht.
Normalerweise ist es ja so, dass ich hier im, im, im, im Stream öfters mal zumindest Sachen mach, wo ich im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt hab, wie's geht.
Nichts, ich hab gar nichts, ich hab keinen Plastenschimmer, wie das funktioniert.
So, wir downloaden das jetzt das erste Mal.
Äh, hast du momentan Urlaub?
Nö, hab ich nicht.
Ich hab, äh, äh, Anfang, äh, Ende November hab ich Urlaub dann.
Also, in vier Wochen oder so.
Hab ich, hab ich, ähm, heute hab ich dann wieder Urlaub.
So, Download geht nicht, weil man sich einen Account machen muss.
Deswegen machen wir uns jetzt erstmal irgendeinen Fake Account.
Don't have to sign up now.
Excellent.
Machen wir, dann machen wir uns mal hier 10-Minute-Mail-Account.
Ich glaub, der da.
Excellent.
Perfekte, die E-Mail-Adresse, genau die brauch ich.
E-Mail.
Passwort.
Äh, alles klar.
Das ist was, was jetzt...
Oh, nee.
Alter, wollt ihr...
Vor allem, ich hab doch, ich hab...
Okay, okay.
Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Dann machen wir es so.
Muss ich mir wieder irgendein Passwort ausdenken, was diesen Kack-Passwort-Richtlinien entspricht.
Was eh kein Mensch braucht.
Okay.
Also.
Jetzt.
Ah.
Groß- und Kleinschreibung.
Gut.
So, tell us, äh, tell us about yourself.
Äh.
Cute.
Chat.
Cellphone.
Null.
Ion...
Wir sind ein Individual.
Address.
Poggers.
Poggers Street.
69.
Wenn schon, wenn schon dann richtig beknackt.
Ähm.
City.
Frankfurt.
Am Main.
Die checken bestimmt nur 60329, ist das?
Select one.
Germany.
Referred language, Englisch.
Warum man das ausfüllen muss, keine Ahnung, das, das, das füllt eh keiner richtig aus.
Äh, for every username.
Omega lul.
Äh, nein, nein, nein, ich will, ich will.
Ich, mir bleibt doch eh nichts anderes übrig, wie yes zu sagen.
Okay, ich agree alles, alles agreed.
Capture, enter Capture, okay.
K, B, 6, V, 5.
Sign up.
Easy.
Nochmal Captchas.
8, H, M.
Never.
Da ist es doch.
Activate your account.
Activate now.
Das war ja einfach.
Das war ja, um nicht zu sagen.
Erstmal schön Fake, erstmal schön Fake Account anlegen.
Enter your password to complete.
Okay, nochmal diesen ganzen Müll eingeben.
Wahrscheinlich braucht man das danach eh nie wieder.
Also, jetzt können wir das ganze Kram runterladen, was braucht man dafür, wie gesagt, ich hab keinen Plan von Vmware, ich hab's zwar schonmal installiert, wir hatten übrigens mal einen, der hat sich bei uns als Linux System Engineer, frag mich nicht, was das genau war, Cloud Services, keine Ahnung, beworben.
Und er hat geschrieben, ähm, er hat Erfahrungen mit Ubuntu.
Er hat fortgeschrittene Linux Erfahrungen und Ubuntu.
Und da haben wir den gefragt, äh, okay, was, was haben sie denn schon gemacht?
Und da hat er allen Ernstes, das ist jetzt kein Witz, ich hab, ich denk mir das nicht aus.
Manchmal denk ich mir Schwachsinn aus, aber das hab ich mir nicht ausgedacht.
Da hat er gesagt, er hat in nem ESX schonmal Ubuntu installiert.
Das war die Windows, das war fortgeschrittene Linux Erfahrungen.
Easy.
Also, wenn das schon fortgeschrittene Linux Erfahrungen ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Okay, was braucht man denn hier alles von?
ESX.
I.
Vorab ISO, das brauchen wir wohl, ne?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, wir, wir agreeen, wir agreeen zu allem, zu allem.
Moment, warum?
Ah, ne, ich muss mir das unter Linux runterladen, ich muss mir das gar nicht hier runterladen.
Was mach ich denn, was mach ich denn für Dinge?
Ich muss mir das hier, okay, erstmal den ganzen, ganzen Shit hier wieder zumachen vom letzten Mal.
Oh, zu, zu viel zugemacht.
So, zack.
Moment, wie heißt meine E-Mail Adresse nochmal?
Aha, hier, alles klar.
Äh, und jetzt muss ich nochmal das Passwort eingeben.
Control-W, beste.
Man kann auch alternativ einfach alles schließen machen, oder nachdem ich jetzt eh den Browser aus Versehen zugemacht hab, hätte ich einfach den Browser schließen können.
Oh, ne, ähm, okay.
Erstmal gleich gebannt.
Da gibt's ne Anleitung, ja, die werd ich mir auch gleich runterladen.
Also, ähm, was brauchen wir denn?
Das da brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
Vor allem wir, vor allem wir, vor allem wir...
Moment.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ne, das brauchen wir nicht, oder? Brauchen wir das?
Doch.
Äh, genau, es gibt nämlich ne Anleitung, das hab ich auch gesehen.
Wie gab's hier? Ja, ja, ach Gott.
Ja.
Rück.
Hier, die Seite brauchen wir.
Da gibt's nämlich den ganzen Kram zum Download.
Okay, das haben wir schon zum...
Accept, ja, ja, wir accepten alles.
Okay, dann kommt man hier raus, alles klar.
Gut, das brauchen wir nicht.
Save das Passwort doch für die Zukunft.
Ich brauch das nicht.
So, und dann haben wir hier nen PDF.
Oh.
Äh, Firefox.
Wow.
Alter, was ist denn...
Eier.
Was ist denn mit euch los?
What the fu...
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist das wieder so ne typische VMware-Anleitung.
Jeglichen Sonderfall abgefackelt.
In Wirklichkeit muss man dreimal klicken und es funktioniert.
Also, require info.
Oh.
Ist a credit...
Blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla, blablabla.
Use case is far edge.
A virtualized IoT gateway.
Ah, far edge, alles klar.
Zum Glück nicht Microsoft Edge.
Cringe joke.
So, was gibt's als nächstes?
Required and supported hardware.
Good power supply, das haben wir.
Ich hab das offizielle...
Was ist das?
3 Ampere...
5 Volt, Dings, Netzteil.
Ich seh, da wird's kaum guter an dem Chat.
Lass mir mal...
Hab ich, hab ich, hab ich...
NSD for UEFI-Firmware.
Micro SD-Kart.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen doppelt geschrieben.
USB-Drive for ISO-Installer.
USB-Drive for...
Moment.
Ich brauch nen USB-Stick und ich brauch nen USB...
Ja, das ist ja gut, hab ich ja alles.
Wozu willst du den ESX auf dem Raspberry Pi inzielen, weil es geht?
Weil ich gucken will, ob's geht und was man dann damit machen kann.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es einen sinnvollen Anwendungsfall dafür gibt,
den man wirklich quasi betreiben will, wo es mit was anderem nicht auch geht.
Es ist eine super Umgebung, glaube ich, um zu üben ein bisschen.
Zum Beispiel ist für mich zum Beispiel eine gute Sache, ich hab ja keinen Plan von VMware.
So, also, das passt alles.
Das haben wir alles.
Ihr seht's ja, ich hab mehr oder weniger alles da.
Also hier, mal gucken.
Ich hab alles da, ich hab einen USB-Stick da.
Zwei SD-Karten da, eine Mikro-SD-Karte, Mikro-SD-Karte, 128G, Mikro-SD-Karten, Reader, ist alles da.
Passt.
Oh, ich nehm es jetzt 216.
Das muss ja korrekt sein.
Underscore 2, Underscore 1, Underscore 6.
Pains Champ, ja.
Okay, also, Power Supply, gut, Power Supply, bla bla bla, haben wir alles.
Jetzt kommt mal zum Punkt.
Der Geek Pie, okay, das ist so eine typische VMware-Anleitung, wo wirklich Gott und die Welt und jeder noch so kleinste Furz, den man lassen kann, irgendwie drinsteht.
Brauchen wir alles nicht, USB-Device, brauchen wir alles nicht, ist alles vollkommen egal.
Ja, hab ich, hab ich gemacht, passt, ist aktuell.
Hab ich, ich hab erst gestern oder so auf dem Raspberry, wir können den nochmal, ich mach nochmal ein Update.
Leute, schade, ich mach nochmal ein Update.
Ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Ich mach ihn mal kurz.
Okay, ja, also, das machen wir mal, das machen wir, ich mach nochmal, ich mach nochmal ein Update, das schadet ja nix, schadet ja nix, wenn wir mal ein Update machen.
Mal gucken, wer da gebootet hat, plinke, plinke.
Ähm, das Ding müsste die gleiche IP haben, wie, wo wir letztens mein Home Assistant Ausbruch, 1, 1, 1, 140.
Haben wir da nicht, bin ich da nicht mal per SSH drauf, 1, 140?
Nmap?
SSH, doch, exzellent.
Wahrscheinlich ist er noch nicht gebootet, ha?
Der, er, er bootet noch vor sich hin.
Müssen wir kurz warten, bis der gebootet ist, dann mach ich nämlich nochmal ein Update.
Ach, da ist er.
Äh, Update.
Ich mach nochmal ein Update.
Man weiß ja nie, man weiß ja nie.
Und dann fangen wir an.
Jetzt seht ihr auch ein paar, ja, seit einer Woche, seit einer Woche ist das raus.
Das ist ganz, ganz fresh ist das.
Wobei fresh sagt man ja heute nicht mehr.
Heute, also, korrigiert mich, wenn ich fallen schliege.
Wenn man heute, wenn man heute irgendwie was zustimmt.
Also, äh, ich bin ja mit 36 jetzt nicht mehr ganz so, ähm, aktuell, was Jugendsprache angeht.
Genau, einmal, es gibt Sachen, die sind wild, wild, wild.
Aber wenn man zustimmt, ähm, dann sagt man auch, was will der denn?
Hä?
Was war das denn jetzt?
Upgrade?
Ja, wenn man zustimmt, dann sagt man, ich fühl's.
Hab ich so, das, hab ich so das Gefühl.
Das man sagt, dass man das dann sagt.
Aber, das fühl ich, sagt man dann.
Das fühl ich, ja.
Ist das so?
Fühl ich, ja.
Digga, genau, fühl ich, Digga.
Ähm, gibt nix zum updaten.
Was, was genau wollte der mir eigentlich hier mit seinem, äh, Kernel-Update-Geschiss sagen?
Gut, ist mir eigentlich wurscht.
Braucht man nicht.
Das fühl ich ist noch älter als fresh.
Nee, das fühl ich, das ist jetzt grad neu.
Lost, lost gibt's auch.
Genau.
Ja, ich bin da nicht so ganz, äh, auf dem aktuellen Stand.
Ist das noch vom 64-Bit-Kernel gewesen?
Kann sein.
Ist aber auch wurscht.
Er hat, er hat alles geupgradet, passt.
Ähm, ich glaub wir können anfangen.
So, also, was, was müssen wir denn jetzt machen?
Plug in SD-Card into Pi and Power.
Was zum?
Sicher?
Das muss man doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr machen.
Ist das nicht normalerweise diese Sache, wo die sogar empfehlen, dass man es nicht macht?
Was passiert denn, wenn man das macht?
Achso.
Ja.
Äh, was auch immer, wir sind moderne, wir sind neuer als das, was die da drauf haben, alles gut.
Ich find's ja toll, dass die bei, von VMware, Screenshots mit ihrem Handy machen vom Terminal.
Da gibt's keine, da gibt's keine, da werden keine ordentlichen, da werden keine Screenshots gemacht.
Und da werden ordentliche Screenshots gemacht.
Und da werden auch keine Capture-Cards verwendet, da wird mit dem Handy abfotografiert.
Die haben kein Geld bei VMware, das muss man verstehen.
Aber VMware ist ja, hat ja auch, ist ja auch keine, keine, äh, kein YouTube-Influencer, sondern VMware machen ja auch ordentliche Sachen.
Da dürfen, die dürfen auch abfotografieren.
Oh, hohe Bildqualität, exzellent.
Shutdown Pi.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt geht's eigentlich los.
Gut, das hätten wir uns jetzt auch sparen können.
Gut.
So, also.
Donut Necessary Bits.
Download, äh, Latest Official Raspberry Pi Firma.
Was machen die da für ultra kompliziertes Zeug?
Das braucht doch kein Mensch.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Die Anleitung ist ultra wir, Alter.
On Windows.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, wir machen das nicht on Windows.
Prepare, wenn, wenn die Anleitung mir zu dumm wird, dann guck ich, ob das auf YouTube schon mal einer installiert hat.
Ich mach das einfach nach.
Also, Prepare SD-Card.
Format SD-Card.
Start with Single FAT32 Partition.
Dazu brauchen wir doch kein Windows.
Sagen wir mal G-Parted auf.
Äh, Moment, erstmal muss ich, Moment, erstmal muss ich die Micro-SD-Card reindecken.
Warum registriert sich das unter Windows?
Das soll sich gefälligst hier registrieren.
Connect.
S.
Exzellent.
So, sudo G-Parted.
Warum, warum soll man das unter Windows machen?
Ich weiß nicht, was, was mit VMware los ist.
Gerade VMware will, dass man die Sache unter Windows vorbereitet.
Dazu fällt mir bloß ein.
Das ist wirklich, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es gemacht hat, aber das ist, das ist Big Brain Emote hier.
So, alles weg da.
Alles, alles weg.
Delete.
Kann ich das nicht deleten?
Ah, ne.
Moment.
Ich hätte fast meine Festplatte gelöscht.
Anstatt den USB-Stick.
Äh, anstatt die Micro-SD-Card.
Ich, Tommy sagt, was, ich raste aus.
Mein Prof antwortet mir jetzt kurz vor dem Bewerbungsgespräch am Mittwoch, ob ich noch Interesse an einer Stelle hätte.
Ist doch gut.
Da kannst du dir beides angucken.
Sag ihm, du hast, du hast Bewerbungsgespräch.
Und, ähm, da kannst du dir beides angucken.
Ist doch nicht verkehrt.
He, he doesn't know.
He lacks critical information.
Okay, ähm.
Ich meine, sag dem ruhig, was du sagst.
Sag dem ruhig, sag dem doch.
Ja, hast du noch Interesse?
Du kannst ihm doch sagen, ich hab, äh, jetzt am Mittwoch oder so ein Vorstellungsgespräch.
Aber, was hat er denn?
Also, ich meine, schadet doch nix, sich das immer alles anzugucken.
So, erstmal alles weg hier.
Alles weg.
Delete, delete.
Accept, delete.
Bam.
So, ähm.
Okay, was?
FAT32 brauchen wir.
Gut, FAT32.
Alles klar.
Wenn der, wenn die FAT32 haben wollen, machen wir FAT32 hier.
FAT.
Wo ist hier FAT32?
FAT32, bam.
Komplett alles FAT32.
Exzellent.
Jetzt haben wir hundert, äh, hundert, hundert, ich wusste gar nicht, dass FAT32 so viel kann.
Ne, warte mal.
War FAT32 nicht bis maximal 4 GB Dateigröße?
War da nicht was?
Ja, doch, ne?
Captain Peng sagt, auf meinem Laptop läuft im Moment PopOS und dank Linux erkennt meine Lüfter nicht.
Hä?
Seit wann muss Linux Lüfter erkennen?
Also.
Es ist eher der umgedrehte Fall, wenn du mit Linux Sensors, ähm, das erkennen lässt, dann kannst du sie leiser machen oder steuern, aber standardmäßig sollten die eigentlich ordentlich kühlen.
So, was hat der hier für Schmerzen?
Oh, weg.
Refresh.
Exzellent.
Fuck, quit.
So, gucken wir mal, ob wir das Ganze mounten können.
Mount, def, ups, mount, def, sd, b, 1 nach m.
M, n, t.
So, und zeigt dem jetzt auch an, das ist ein schönes, ne, BLK-ID war das.
Was ist, oh, exzellent.
Moment.
V-FAT?
Hab ich V-FAT genommen oder, oder, oder, oder, oder FAT32?
V-FAT ist ja eigentlich was anderes, ne?
Ich hab FAT32 genommen.
Ich guck nochmal nach.
Ne, hab ich, passt.
Okay.
Äh, Moment, vielleicht soll ich ihm noch sagen, dass man das mounten kann, dass er es booten kann.
Das machen wir noch.
Noch boot, boot, flag.
Wo setzt man hier flags?
Checks, manage flags?
Boot.
Wir setzen nochmal boot, flag.
Das ist bei so oldschool Sachen nicht verkehrt.
Warum kann ich das nicht applyen?
Wurscht.
Okay, also, mounten wir den ganzen Krempel.
Mount.
Zack.
So, und was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Also, on Windows brauchen wir das Ganze schon mal gar nicht machen.
Okay, open up Windows.
Ähm, okay, das haben wir gemacht.
Was wird hier?
Wir installieren ESX auf einem Raspberry Pi.
Das gibt seit einer Woche eine Beta-Version.
Okay, ich muss wirklich diesen Mist runterladen.
Das da muss ich runterladen?
Was ist das?
Das hab ich noch nie...
Okay, ich lad das andere auch nochmal runter.
Das hab ich noch nie gebraucht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das existiert.
Okay, also, jetzt muss ich...
Firmware-Master-Zip extrahieren.
Das geht ja schon gut los.
Okay, download.
Jetzt schon kein Bock mehr auf die Installation, ja.
Moin, wie weit bist du mit der Installation?
Wir haben noch...
Wir bereiten gerade den USB-Stick und das Zeug vor dafür.
So.
Hallo?
Download nicht fertig?
Doch.
Also, unzip.
Firmware-Master.
Wow.
Da alles drauf.
So, und was soll ich?
Was soll ich jetzt machen?
Extract Firmware-Master and delete all files starting with kernel-image.
Firmware-Master boot.
Man kann's den Leuten aber auch echt das Leben schwer machen, oder?
Was ist das für eine Installation schon wieder?
Also, was?
Ich soll alles löschen mit Kernel.
Okay, machen wir.
Alles Kernel.
Wird gelöscht.
Excellent.
Sonst haben wir hier nichts mehr mit Kernel drin stehen.
Okay, wunderbar.
Ja, das ist ja gut, dass da der fix-up-4-db-dat dabei ist.
Da ist ganz schön viel fix.
Hier fix.
Fix-up-4x.
Fix-up-xd.
Fix-up-cd.
Dass da alles gefixt wird.
So, haben wir gemacht.
And copy entire boot directory onto newly formatted SD-Card.
Das machen wir mal.
Also, root.
Home.
Max.
Download.
Firmware-Master.
Boot.
Man muss übrigens cp-r machen, weil ansonsten kopiert das nicht.
So, da haben wir es.
Wollen wir den Inhalt oder muss man boot kopieren?
Okay, nein.
Man soll das ganze Verzeichnis auf die SD-Karte kopieren.
Okay, haben wir gemacht.
Weil es hätte ja auch sein können, dass man den Inhalt von boot direkt auf das root von
der SD-Karte.
Aber ich glaube, die wollen, dass man den Ordner kopiert.
So, und jetzt brauchen wir extract exquisite high-quality images hier bei VMware.
Ah, yes.
Also, ich glaube, die Datei ist ganz besonders wichtig hier unten.
Also, Leute, es ist nicht so, dass der Stream gerade Encoding-Probleme hätte oder so.
Das erkennt man wirklich nicht.
Trimolon.
Null.
Trimolon sagt, aber krass, dass VMware noch Master benutzt.
GitHub hat das ja geändert.
Ja, stimmt.
Also, mal ganz ehrlich.
Warum benutzt VMware Master?
Das finde ich ja highly offensive.
Könnten sie das nicht main?
Oder staging?
Oder anders nennen?
Master geht ja mal gar nicht hier.
Anzeige ist raus.
Also, was muss ich jetzt machen?
Und schon gar nicht, wenn die Chinesen das machen.
Was muss ich jetzt machen?
Extract Raspberry Pi Firmware zip and copy all files with them direct into the same boot
directory.
Okay, das ist natürlich ein äußerst super hilfreicher Screenshot.
Aber ich will jetzt mal die Anzeige auswählen.
Was ist denn das?
Ich habe es jetzt hier.
Ich habe es hier.
Also, das ist jetzt ein äußerst super hilfreicher Screenshot.
Das bringt mir ganz, ganz viel, dass ich jetzt erkenne.
Okay, also das heißt, ich soll jetzt zurückgehen.
Ich soll Anzip machen auf UEFI.
Ne, wie heißt das?
Anzip auf UEFI Firmware.
Oh, hat er das jetzt?
Nein.
Ich hasse, wenn diese Dinger so kacke eingepackt sind.
Jetzt hat er das nicht in den extra Ordner entpackt, sondern direkt in das Download verzeichnet.
Ja, ganz toll.
Okay, MKDier verschieben wir es halt nochmal und anzippen das nochmal hier.
So, also was?
Ich soll jetzt alles von hier, alles von hier in das Boot-Verzeichnis hier kopieren.
Habe ich das richtig?
Also Chat, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas verkehrt verstanden habe, sag mir Bescheid.
Also, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, ich soll alles von hier, okay, das eine löschen wir mal hier.
Ich soll alles von hier nach da kopieren?
Mach es doch lieber über Windows.
Warum? Das macht es doch auch nicht, dass es da auch kommt.
Absolut kein Unterschied, ob ich das jetzt unter Windows mache, die Anleitung, oder hier.
So, habe ich gemacht.
Alles hin kopiert.
Also, da ist eins, ja, ja, genau, hier und da.
Alles, alles hin kopiert.
So, und was macht man jetzt?
4 GB Pi-Only, Edit, Config.txt, und was?
GPU-MEM gleich 16.
Ach, das ist, dass mehr, Alter, das ist, dass ich mehr RAM frei habe für ESX, ha?
GPU-MEM gleich 16, okay.
Eject SD-Card and put SD-Card into Raspberry Pi.
Ach, gibt es auch eine Linux-Anleitung?
Hätte ich vielleicht mal weiter scrollen sollen.
U-Mount.
Okay, wir scrollen erstmal weiter, was jetzt noch kommt.
Das ist die Mac-Anleitung.
Ja, das haben wir schon alles gemacht unter Linux.
Nur, dass es hier jetzt nochmal, zeigen wir jetzt, wie es auf dem Mac geht.
Okay, Design on your Console Choice.
HDMI plus USB.
Ja, exakt, so machen wir das.
HDMI und USB-Keyboard machen wir.
Oh, da brauche ich meine Capture-Card gleich.
Wiring.
Okay, das ist egal, das brauchen wir alles nicht.
Was für eine Anleitung, Alter.
Ach, man kann das auch über einen Terminal installieren.
Okay, das ist gar nicht so blöd, aber um Raspberry Pi kann man ja einfach was anschließen, was gut ist.
Skip zu, zu was soll ich skippen?
Skip zu?
Skip zu 3, 3, 4 soll ich skippen, ne?
Ja.
UEFI-Configuration.
You can use USB, HDMI-USB-Keyboard.
Power to Raspberry Pi.
And then keep mashing Escape-Key when prompted.
Okay, ich, ich war noch nie im BIOS vom Raspberry Pi oder was auch immer das jetzt genau ist, in die UEFI-Shell.
Boah, ist das kompliziert, der Install, ey.
Was auch immer sie sich da ausgaben.
Okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt erstmal meine Capture-Card anschließen.
Okay, Capture-Card.
Warum gibt es dafür nicht einfach ein Image?
Das ist der Filter von VMware.
Nur Big Brain.
Und Leute sind erlaubt, ESXi auf dem Raspberry Pi zu installieren.
Das bedeutet, man muss den Installer kompliziert machen.
So, ich schließe mal meine Capture-Card ab.
Einzig mit USB-Kabel, was ich habe.
Und 3D.
Das heißt, jetzt müssen wir wirklich auf dem Raspberry Pi ins BIOS.
Das habe ich noch, noch nie gemacht.
KennyTV sagt, du hast mit Programmieren und so nix am Hut.
Findest du das doch nice, wenn dir das gefällt?
Ich finde das auch immer schön, wenn Leute, die jetzt vielleicht nicht,
den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Technik-Sachen machen, trotzdem da sogar was abgewinnen können.
So, auf geht's.
Elgato.
Elgato, mal vor dich hin.
Mach mal.
Ach so, der Raspberry Pi ist ja aus.
Keck weh.
Ähm, okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt die Tastatur umstöpseln.
Meine Güte, das ist ja richtig Turnschuh-Installation hier.
Du musst ja permanent hin und her laufen.
Jetzt muss ich die Tastatur anschließen noch am Raspberry Pi.
Okay, mache ich, mache ich, mache ich.
Mache mal alles, kein Problem.
Tastatur.
Jetzt muss ich Escape hemmen, Alter, Alter.
Escape.
Kamera, Escape.
Die haben gesagt, ich soll Escape drücken.
Äh.
Ah.
Oh, ich bin ja blöd.
Also, ich hab's falsch gemacht, Leute.
Erstens, ich hab die SD-Karte nicht eingelegt.
Und zweitens, ich hab noch die alte SSD dran, die bootet.
Das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren, ey.
Okay, noch mal.
Noch mal.
Hier.
Wieder.
Ja, da.
Jetzt da hier irgendwo.
Und jetzt Escape drücken.
Escape.
Volle Pulle, Escape.
Das Ding wieder aufsetzen.
Escape.
Let's go.
What?
Was zum?
Nein!
Das kann jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein, oder?
Wie jetzt?
Das geht nicht?
Ich veräpple mich, ich veräpple mich.
Das muss funktionieren.
Standard.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das muss gehen.
What the fuck?
Ey, ich stell einfach auf du...
Ich stell einfach...
iPad.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Die wollen mir doch nicht wirklich erzählen, ich kann das jetzt nicht machen, weil meine
kack Capture Card die Auflösung nicht supportet.
Wie kann man 640x480 nicht supporten?
640x480, was anderes, was anderes gibt es?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Und jetzt?
Was mach ich jetzt?
was muss man überhaupt hier drin machen okay ich muss die tastatur ich muss die
tastatur wieder umstecken ich muss die tastatur wieder umstöpseln
mal kurz okay 46 x 84 not supported change warum ist das bios überhaupt so
eine bescheuerte ok also suchen wir mal was muss man hier überhaupt machen drin
also escape drücken serial console ok das interessiert mich nicht in case
ja das able drei gigabyte memory limit ok ok ok ok man muss das man muss das
machen das geht nicht ohne der chill freak hat eine lösung geschickt zeigt
man ja und wenn ein switch in obs okay okay in obs sollen wir das jetzt machen
warum muss man so was über obs machen und kann das nicht einfach hier drin in
der in der in der game capture machen
das für ein schwachsinn schon wieder hd 60 640 x 480 das muss doch gehen
okay da machen wir es doch über da machen wir es doch über obs jetzt alles
klar also ich hätte ehrlich gesagt nicht
gedacht dass das unser hauptsächliches problem jetzt sein wird das bios vom
raspberry pi angezeigt zu bekommen hier gehen wir mal hier rüber szene
szene
weg also machen wir machen wir machen sie jetzt auf mal ich mache es in der
anderen szene leute weil bei eigentlich eigentlich ist egal im zweifel kann ich
die szene wechseln guck mal at game capture wenig game capture was
manchen und wie ging das noch mal etwas musste man noch mal machen damit man das
einbinden video capture die weiße musik ist aus
okay und was muss ich jetzt machen
wave
kơnfeger im european
bestseller
ernst sein
ich glaub's
super
geil
das kann halt nicht
ernst
okay
moment leute dann könnt ihr halt nicht zu gucken ich kann das am anderen
monitor machen ich kann das am anderen monitor machen
dann könnt ihr halt nicht zu gucken so wie kriegt man das hier jetzt rein
das ist doch mal richtig hängen geblieben
das muss doch gehen das muss doch gehen
alles klar jetzt haben wir fullscreen jetzt können wir uns den fullscreen
angucken dass es not supported ist natürlich noch viel ist ja gleich viel
besser du kannst du nichts klicken
640 x 480 oh warte und jetzt mag er jetzt kann das
video aha aha aha pause champ pause champ was jetzt aha
exzellent ok wir machen nochmal deactivate
ok wir machen nochmal deactivate
ok wie kriegt man hd hd 60 x 480 input bei 640 warum ist es auch sechs warum
ist das auch so oldschool 640 x 480 hast du kein mini hdmi adapter herr was
soll das bringen natürlich sonst könnte ich das würde doch gar nichts sehen gut
also das tut sich hier anscheinend nicht so gut aber ich glaube ich kann das
schon mal gar nichts gut dann könnt ihr da jetzt nicht zu gucken dann muss ich
jetzt einfach das mal schnell auf dem zweiten monitor machen weil ich kann
nicht mal mehr hier die ich kann nicht mal die config settings aufmachen
wir löschen das mal wieder
ja nicht kann ich jetzt jetzt ob es der
ja nicht kann ich jetzt jetzt ob es der heute ob es ist der läuft das stream
heute ob es ist der läuft das stream
heute ob es ist der läuft das stream doch jetzt dritten läuft doch auf ob es
geht wieder sehr gut exzellent hd 60 raspberry pi man kann das alles die captcha kann jetzt
komplett rip ist dass die jetzt einfach gar nichts mehr macht die macht jetzt gar nichts mehr die
man was ist das für eine kacke warum kann die so eine gängige auflösung wie 640 x 480 net aha
moment what the fuck man kann die auflösung umstellen man kann die auflösung in der boot
boot stings man kann aber die raspberry pi boot auflösung umstellen or big brain jetzt
okay wir stellen jetzt die raspberry pi boot auflösung um das war jetzt mal gucken ob das
dann funktioniert keck trippel juli assiste mit so problem hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet warum
hat er das jetzt nicht verbunden moment gut also das heißt wir müssen jetzt raspberry pi
und
so und da gehen wir jetzt in die system wollen das ist schon mal nicht gut wenn das da ist wo
kommt das her wo kommt das her was ist das hier für eine kacke was ist das für ein müll das ist
irgendwas von windows das ist irgendwas von windows weil das in windows gemountet war warum schreibt
windows einfach ungefragt irgendein müll auf die auf den usb stick oder auf dem micro sd karte ok
also gut und fickt sowie
wie stellt man jetzt die auflösung ein bei boot resolution config.txt aber mir hat noch
eben irgendwas gefunden habe ich jetzt irgendwas wir haben bloß 16 mb ram wir haben bloß 16 mb
grafikspeicher also ganz so viel kann man das einstellen frei format was der resolution set
monitor resolution hier hdmi mode 16 ach du große scheiße was soll ich denn alles einstellen
ok 1024 768 sollte klappen ist das sinnvoll einfach sowas hier rein zu kopieren er für bann
musste er subscribe ob ich kopiere das jetzt hier einfach mal rein ich habe keine ahnung was das
macht ich habe wirklich keinen blassen schimmer not for raspberry pi 4 because has to some commands
can be applied to ach so ach du scheiße jetzt muss ich das auch noch einstellen was 1024 moment elgato
hd 60 support resolutions die können das kann ja gar nichts das kann ja gar nichts an auflösung
report ist leufe port specify ich probiere das jetzt einfach aus wenn ich geht stöpsel ich
schnell um also hat er im mod hdmi drive sound ist mir vollkommen egal was ist was ist dmt ok lasst es
jetzt einfach so lasst es jetzt einfach so lasst es jetzt einfach so lasst es jetzt einfach so
Einfach mit iPhone-Kamera filmen.
Nee, das geht nicht.
Okay, ich stöpsel es nochmal um.
Mal Game Capture aufmachen.
Escape-Hämmern.
So, Pause-Champ. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt geht.
Pause-Champ.
Ich hab's doch gerade umgestellt.
Warum? Ich hab übrigens gerade Escape gehämmert.
Obwohl ich die Tastatur gar nicht angeschlossen hatte.
He doesn't know.
Aber da müsste der jetzt nochmal...
Ja, aber selbst dann sollte er doch irgendwas einblenden.
Okay, ich stöpsel die Tastatur nochmal um.
Mal gucken, ob das was bringt, aber ich glaube nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt folgendes machen...
Ich stöpsel einfach...
Man kann ja das durch die Elgato durchschleifen.
Ich stöpsel mir den Kram jetzt an den Monitor dran, um gut ist.
Pech.
Nee.
So.
Ich stöpsel.
Ich stöpsel mich jetzt irgendwo an den Monitor.
Ich brauch nochmal hier irgendwo noch einen freien Anschluss.
Wo hat denn dieser Monitor...
Wo hat denn mein neuer Monitor seine Ports?
Sind die unten oder sind die an der Seite?
Die sind unten, hä?
Wisst ihr, was ich nicht kapiere?
Warum machen die die Ports für die Monitore...
Warum machen die die immer noch unten hin, anstatt an die Seite?
An die Seite.
An die Seite wäre doch viel, viel praktischer.
Anstatt unten hin, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
So.
Wo ist denn hier der Anschluss?
Ich muss gerade mal meinen Monitor rumdrehen.
Weil ich habe ja einen neuen Monitor und da ist bisher nur ein HDMI-Kabel dran.
Hier.
Da kann man das Kabel nicht so gut verstecken, ja.
Irgendwo.
Ach du Scheiße.
In welchem Winkel muss man denn jetzt hier dran?
Okay.
Ich habe es angeschlossen.
Excellent.
So, mal kurz rumdrehen.
Das Ganze und den Monitor wieder runter machen.
Zack.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Also, ich werde jetzt mal meinen Monitor umschalten auf HDMI-Input.
Und euch mal kurz nicht sehen.
Wenn ich finde, wo man den Input überhaupt umschalten kann hier.
System.
Wo schaltet man den?
Display?
Input.
HDMI.
Ist das HDMI 1 oder ist das HDMI 2?
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Ah.
Ich sehe den Raspberry Pi.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Also, Chat.
Oh, jetzt muss...
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt sehe ich ja gar nicht, was ich machen muss.
Aber.
Ich sehe den Raspberry Pi.
Das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Ähm.
Das Problem ist, ich erkenne jetzt hier gar nichts drauf.
SD-Karte.
SD-Karte detected.
Ja, ihr seht es jetzt nicht.
Der Endlos bootet hier gerade von der SD-Karte irgendwie.
Vielleicht habe ich auch nicht schnell genug
Escape gedrückt oder so.
Was?
Jetzt hat sich mein Monitor wieder umgestellt.
Hast du die SD-Karte richtig aus?
Nee, doch.
Stimmt.
Display.
Input.
HDMI1.
Nee, ich habe jetzt wieder das gleiche.
Ich komme nicht in dieses komische BIOS da rein.
Keine Chance.
Meine Tastatur-Lager.
wird auch überhaupt nicht erkannt normalerweise wenn die tastatur angeht
dann hat die tastatur nennen dann ist es eltern ist die beleuchtung von der
tastatur an die ist nicht an ich kann auch ich kann überhaupt nichts machen
hier dran ja das ist wohl doch nicht so einfach wie
sich das vorgestellt hat
leute ich habe keine ahnung was machen soll
was war man denn jetzt nur ich habe keine ich habe nicht noch 20.000
andere tastaturen rumliegen was wir auf den sack geht ist dass der monitor sich
umschaltet sobald ich den raspberry pi ausmachen das ist sehr das ist
extrem er schaltet sich direkt um der monitor ja was ist das denn
ich will sehen wie der bootet und ich jedes mal umschalten muss
der mag das der mag davon nicht zu booten
der mag nicht davon zu booten der hat da keinen bock drauf soll mal kurz den
monitor abgewöhnen dass der umschaltet ich wüsste wo das geht system settings
interface
input auto switcher off sehr gut gut da kann ich noch mal resetten und zugucken
würde erkennt meine tastatur nicht probieren mal hdmi group kann ich mal
kann ich ausprobieren ich glaube nicht dass es was ändert aber jetzt muss ich
erst mal mein input wieder switchen system input displayport dort sehe ich
euch bitte so ok ich mache jetzt mal also ich habe keine ahnung ach so ist die
tastatur ist ja noch am raspberry pi
so ok wir gucken jetzt irgendwie dass wir das bei überredet kriegen das auf der
elgato funktioniert weil ansonsten ist es ja noch echt komplette zumutung hat er
jetzt die sdk kann immer meinen standardmäßig meinen kartenleser please
in der vm erkennen und nicht immer so bescheuert über windows warten michael
fünf spieljahren dankeschön exquisite subscription gut sag mal ist das für ist
vielleicht die vmware anleitung einfach nur kacke
so
dass wir das dass man das gar nicht hier in diesen ordner machen muss das ist
einfach nur sagt aber die vmware anleitung nicht richtig ist was soll ich
mal ausprobieren hdmi group mode 82 wisst ihr was ich gucke jetzt mal auf
youtube und ob da irgendeiner schon mal was gemacht ist schon mal gemacht hat
okay er ist xp
ja easy
was geht all sein
pues Rudy
ja michael stimmt du hast gestern schon mal subs ski
was ist denn schon mal selbst babys
keine ahnung was damit wir bloß ist
reflektiert
so wie gesagt
nein
berichtitionsfeld und ist an der restplatte auf settings vier bühlersser mit abgefucktly
capt tschenko opferennes jungen so äußerst oft in einer schworldencerise ver Sortierter
Kann das sein, dass der, ich soll kurz gucken, ob der noch das richtige Sachen eingestellt hat.
Oder ist das nur das Video von dem Typ?
Ne, passt.
Ne, alles gut, alles richtig.
Ne, man kann nicht zweimal subben, Michael. Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Es kann sein, dass du gestern Prime gesubbt hast und heute nochmal, dann kannst du den Prime-Sub aber woanders vergeben.
Würde ich mal von ausgehen.
Also, okay, okay, okay, also, Moment, Moment, Moment, langsam.
Okay, auf, zeig her.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, gut, das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Ja.
Ja, das haben wir auch gemacht.
Und in Windows, you could just use your regular formatter to format it back to FAT32.
So, once I'm done with this, I have a ton of free space, I'm gonna hit the plus.
Jetzt auf einmal doch Facecam, ja.
Space, next, and I'm just gonna name this boot.
Muss man das boot nennen?
It is.
Then I'm gonna turn this into for use of all.
System, FAT, and I'm gonna erase.
Actually, no, it's gonna take longer, so I'm just gonna let that go through.
It's gonna create the partition, and there we have it.
FAT32, it's not mounted, it's...
Okay, ich mach das jetzt nochmal.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich mach das, wobei, ich guck erst mal.
Ich guck...
Exactly what I need it to be.
So, now I can mount the system, and it's gonna be called boot, and I have 31 gigs free, which is the smallest memory card I have available right now.
Ja, ich hab 128.
Das sollte ja nicht das Problem sein.
Ja, das haben wir alles gemacht.
Und jetzt Kernel weg.
Kernel.
Ja, das haben wir alles gemacht.
Moment.
Die Vorhineinwahl-Anleitung ist scheiße.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht, was die geschrieben haben.
Die, die schreiben...
Moment, Moment.
Die schreiben...
Guckt mal.
Hier, passt mal auf.
Das ist, die haben mich jebaited.
So, also, passt mal auf.
Die schreiben...
Ähm...
Extract...
Delete...
And copy the entire boot directory onto newly formatted...
Die meinen nicht, dass man das Verzeichnis...
Auf den USB-Stick kopieren soll.
Die meinen, man soll den Inhalt des Verzeichnisses auf den USB-Stick kopieren.
Meine Fresse, wer hat denn das geschrieben, ey?
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal diese Anleitung fertig.
So, it's gonna copy that over to the memory card.
Alright, and we are done with that.
And next, we're gonna head back into the other firmware, which is the Raspberry Pi UEFI
Firmware.
Pop into...
Kein Wunder, dass der Kram nicht bootet.
...to that.
And copy everything from here.
All right.
Over to that same partition.
And you're gonna just merge everything, overwrite everything, whatever you wanna do.
And I'm just gonna...
Okay, okay.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Damit...
Ich mach das jetzt...
Ich track und drop das meinetwegen jetzt auch über den GUI.
Ist mir wurscht.
Okay, also.
Wir unmounten den Kram mal wieder.
Ähm...
So.
Ich mach...
Ja, ja.
Ja, geh weg.
G...
Parted.
Okay.
Und jetzt nicht meine Festplatte, sondern die SD-Karte.
Ich lösche das alles noch mal.
Zack.
Okay.
Device.
New Partition.
Create Partition Table.
MS-DOS.
Apply.
Alles gut.
So.
Jetzt sagen wir ihm.
New FAT 32 Partition.
Alles.
Label Boot.
Partition Name.
Ja gut.
Das ist das Gleiche.
Alles klar.
Zack.
Boot.
okay meine güte was eine kacke anleitung so jetzt gehen wir noch hinsagen check
manager flags und setzen noch mal gut das hat er zwar nicht gemacht aber das
kann ja nicht schaden dass man das auch gut war macht was will er mir eigentlich
hiermit sagen hat irgendeiner plan was der was der möchte von mir
ach so das ist fast 32 ist klar dass der das nicht kann
so mount mnt so und jetzt müssen wir nicht etwa das den den boot ordner
kopieren wie das wie das vor allem mal geschrieben hat sondern den inhalt so
passt mal ob ich mache das jetzt sogar mit macht sie macht es ja sogar mit
irgendeinem file manager hier boot ach moment das ist mein boot das ist mein
boot das ist gerade hoch kann deswegen ich benutze nie irgendwelche
gute sachen zum kopieren wo ist das jetzt überhaupt hier
an ich habe da keinen zugriff drauf ich mache ich mache es über kommando zeile
dass die anfälle so also wir sollen jetzt alles kopieren aus diesem
raspberry pi firmware ordner cd firmware so und dort gehen wir jetzt
nach boot und wir kopieren nicht den boot ordner die kopieren alles von dem
boot ordner
also home max downloads firmware master boot so alles daraus dahin
ach so ja minus er so sehr gut jetzt ergibt jetzt ergibt es auch schon jetzt
ergibt das nämlich auch schon mehr sinn so und jetzt kopieren wir noch alles aus
dem uefi uefi zeug kopieren wir auch hier hin den ganzen kam kopieren wir auch hierher
so und jetzt gehen wir in die config rein und sagen gpu gpu mem das da so und jetzt geht es
wahrscheinlich auch einfach juma und mnt habe ich irgendwas vergessen
jetzt vergesst alles was verwendet werden muss das für die nächste selektion
ja ja bla bla
verwendet
jetzt eine Sache die notwendig ist nachdem du alle filen über den boot folder getrennt bist
gehst du in die konfiguration
das haben wir schon gemacht
ja gpu
gpu mem
ja
ja ja ja ach irgendwie
ein ordentliches
ja moment das iso flaschen war auch gleich noch das haben das muss
ich glaube ich herunterladen keine ahnung das bin haltём
horsepower
ich habeicion
und schmecken
jr ISO Apost sle stipto
in die Areßen
empfehlegte
Test
Das machen wir noch.
Wir machen das jetzt genau.
Wir mounten das nochmal und machen das jetzt mit der Auflösung.
CD, Wim, Config.
Jetzt frisst es der Raspberry Pi bestimmt auch.
Also.
Pi, Boot, Resolution.
Nein, nein, nein.
Config.
TXT.
Was ist ein DMT?
Display Monitor Time.
Das klingt schon super nach Wissenschaft für sich.
Was ist ein CA Group und was ist ein DMT Group?
What the fuck?
Warum ist der Kram immer so ultra kryptisch alles?
Erwartet jetzt wirklich, dass ich...
Okay.
Ich nehme die DMT Group.
Alles klar.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist, aber ich nehme die DMT Group.
Ja.
Okay.
Nehmen wir mal 85.
Also.
HDMI Mode.
85.
85 ist...
700...
Ist...
1280 mal 720.
Excellent.
Sehr gut.
Gut.
Unmount.
Sync.
Alles gut.
So, jetzt nehmen wir mal Edger auf.
Und machen noch das ISO drauf.
Auf USB Stick.
Ich habe hier so einen richtig alten...
Alten Mega Crap USB Stick.
So ein uralt...
8G USB Stick.
Aber das sollte es dafür tun.
Topics.
Dankeschön.
Zwei Monate.
Glaubst du, dass MW2 Remastered MP noch...
Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Aber man weiß nie, wenn die Geld brauchen vielleicht wieder.
Okay.
Downloads.
Ja.
Das da.
What?
Continue.
Mache einfach.
Auf den 8 GB USB Stick.
Flash.
Amazon hat es geblockt.
Echt?
Warum...
Warum?
Warum blockt Amazon Prime Subscriptions?
Total beknackt.
War deaktiv...
Echt, man kann das deaktivieren?
Lull.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal kurz das Video noch fertig an.
Ja, ja, das hatten wir gerade schon.
Und dann...
Gib das ein paar Minuten.
Es ist nur ein kleines File.
135 MB.
Es wird super schnell transferiert.
Und du bist fertig.
Sobald das fertig ist,
hast du dein USB Stick.
Für den UEFI Boot, den du in dein Raspberry Pi installieren wirst.
Ja.
Und dann deinen USB Installer.
Lass uns weiter mit dem Installieren auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Also, das erste Mal, wenn du das bootest,
willst du in die Settings des UEFI einsteigen.
Und ein paar Dinge fixieren.
Also, im Device Manager...
Ja, Moment. Das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Das müssen wir jetzt machen.
Hoffentlich geht das jetzt.
Hoffentlich checkt er das.
Jetzt bin ich...
Chat, was meint ihr?
Geht's oder geht's net?
Postchamp oder nicht Postchamp, ist jetzt die Frage.
Ich meine, wir haben es jetzt richtig gemacht.
Vorher haben wir es falsch gemacht.
Ups.
Es geht.
Geht nicht.
Oh je.
Chat, Chat.
Porgas.
Es geht.
Leute, ich kann...
Ich...
Ich hab ein Problem.
Ich kann den Bildschirm nicht wechseln,
weil ich die Tastatur nicht angeschlossen hab.
Jetzt kann ich...
Ich kann den Postchamp nicht wegmachen.
Ah, doch.
Easy.
So, ich kann den Postchamp doch wegmachen.
So.
Okay, was...
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Raspberry Pi Configuration.
Moment, wo...
What the...
Moment, was?
Wie?
Wo?
Device Manager.
Und dann Raspberry Pi Manager.
Nee, Configuration.
Device Manager.
You wanna head over to...
Let me see.
Übrigens, ich muss...
Ich muss jetzt erst mal was loswerden.
Eigene Sache, dass das jetzt funktioniert hat.
So, jetzt können wir weitergucken.
Raspberry Pi Configuration.
And I believe...
I believe it's Advanced Configuration.
Advanced Configuration.
Limit RAM to 3G.
Disabled wahrscheinlich, ne?
Vermute ich jetzt mal.
Limit RAM to 3GB.
You have to disable that.
Ja.
This way I allow you to use...
Excellent.
4GB, 8GB.
Once you are done with this...
Exquisite.
You will hit save.
And I'm gonna reset the machine just to make sure that it's taking an effect.
Okay.
Also, save ist F10.
Save Configuration.
Change.
Yes.
Ah, das bringt englische Tastatur.
Ich muss mit Z drücken.
Ja.
So, now that I booted up again, I'm popping back into the configurations.
And I'm gonna change into Boot Manager.
Boot Manager.
It's gonna boot up from my USB.
So, I'm gonna go into Boot Manager.
Okay, da muss ich USB erst mal anschließen.
Ja, das muss man erst mal anschließen.
Okay.
So, also, was hat der Typ jetzt gemacht?
Reset.
Und jetzt nochmal Escape hämmern.
Machen wir.
So.
Musik an.
Und jetzt was?
Boot Manager?
Hallo?
Machen wir mal Fullscreen, please.
Boot Manager?
Äh.
Und jetzt das da, hä?
Ja.
Also, dieser ist beneficial.
Der ist fun directions also, der muss Jane ferry machen.
Ja, genau.
Weil von dem, von dem muss er eigentlich booten.
Use Keys To Choose.
Enter To Select Boot Option.
What.
Wow!
Achso, easy.
Jetzt boot der direkt davon.
Das sieht doch nach einem ES6 Installer aus.
An einem richtig, echten.
Legit Real ESX Installer.
Da sieht jetzt, der sieht so hässlich aus.
Die sahen schon immer so hässlich aus.
Ich habe die scheiß Anleitung von VMware weggeschmissen und habe es mir in einem YouTube-Video angeguckt, weil in der VMware-Anleitung steht, man soll den Boot-Ordner kopieren, was wir auch gemacht haben.
Was die meinten ist, man soll den Inhalt des Boot-Ordners kopieren.
So, und dann sind wir in den Boot-Config gegangen und haben gesagt, dass wir 720p als HDMI-Options haben wollen.
Und dadurch, dass die Dateien jetzt auch im richtigen Verzeichnis lagen auf der SD-Karte, hat es der Raspberry Pi auch eingelesen und es ging.
Gleich Windows VM probieren, Windows für ARM können wir probieren, ja.
Oh, das ist eine gute Asana, das müssen wir halt, falls ich vergesse, schreibt das gleich nochmal, das probieren wir aus, ARM Windows installieren wir da drauf.
Chat, denk mit dran, wir installieren Windows ARM Edition drauf.
So.
Ich.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens in letzter Zeit nicht in den Chat geguckt, ich scrolle mal kurz durch, während es installiert.
Also, ich gucke mal kurz, da ist irgendwas, ich habe garantiert viele Sachen übersehen.
Oh, was war das?
Was war das?
War das ein Error?
Monka Smoke?
War es kaputt?
Ne, der ist fertig.
Oh.
Failing?
Was, Failing?
Ach ne, Fling.
Ich habe Failing gelesen, Alter.
Und jetzt?
Ich gucke mal kurz, was der Dude macht.
Er macht noch was anderes vorher, guck mal.
Oh ne, das haben wir nicht gemacht.
Jetzt müssen wir das nochmal machen gleich.
Jetzt kannst du es sehen, es sagt Run Weasel und CD-ROM Boot.
Du brauchst hier noch eine andere Option hinzufügen, die heißt Auto Partition OS Data.
Was?
Size, so.
Siehst du, ich habe hier die Kapitel P, die Kapitel OS, die Kapitel D.
Was?
Alter.
Meine Güte, ist das kompliziert.
Kapitel Size equals 8192.
Okay, was das macht, ist eigentlich, weil wir nur ein Install Media oder ein Storage Device haben,
wollen wir nicht, dass der Installer die Enteiltheit davon abnehmen will, dass wir...
Achso, ne, ne, ne, das ist okay.
Das ist okay.
Das ist okay, ich mache eh gleich eine SSD dran.
Das bedeutet, wir werden keine Daten-Storage schaffen, um unsere Operationssysteme oder...
Eine Daten-Storage mache ich eh nicht auf die SD-Karte, die Daten-Storage kommt eher auf SSD drauf.
... auf VMs.
Also, wir schneiden nur 8 GB nur für das Operationssystem mit diesem kleinen Befehl.
Und dann wird der Rest der freien Raum, was du hast, für deine Daten-Store dediziert.
Wenn du nicht...
Ne, das ist okay.
Daten-Store will ich eh nicht auf die SD-Karte haben.
Wenn du diesen Befehl einbringst, musst du eine andere USB oder eine andere SSD installieren,
damit du das in eine Daten-Store einbauen kannst, was ungewöhnlich ist.
Und, weil das wirklich für Testen ist, ist das perfekt.
Ne, ne, das mache ich. Ich habe ja schon eine SSD nebendran liegen dafür.
Ja, wenn du damit anfängst, ist das Rest sehr einfach zu installieren.
Okay.
Jetzt, dass es fertig ist, werden wir auf F1 klicken, um weiterzumachen.
Klick auf F1, um weiterzumachen.
Akzeptiere die ULA.
Die ULA?
Und es wird für die verfügbaren Geräte gespeichert.
Ich akzeptiere auch gleich die ULA.
Du solltest deine USB-SD-Karte oder USB-was auch immer aufnehmen.
Also, mein Cruiser Blade.
Das ist das Install-Media, mit dem ich nichts machen werde.
Ja.
Aber das ist der aktuelle andere Harddrive, den ich habe oder die andere USB-SD-Karte, die ich habe.
Ja, da mache ich die SSD dran.
Also, ich klicke auf das.
Klick OK, um zu installieren.
Äh, USB-SD-Karte.
Okay, das heißt, ich muss jetzt schon die SSD anschließen, weil sonst mag er nicht.
Das machen wir jetzt mal schnell.
Guck da.
Du bist heiß.
Ey, der Raspberry Pi ist brutal heiß.
Ich greife den unten am RJ45-Netzwerk-Port an.
Und ich will nicht sagen, dass man sich die Finger verbrennt, das wäre übertrieben.
Aber der ist schon ganz schön warm.
Was jetzt wieder?
Alter, was jetzt?
Okay, ich glaube, ich muss den nochmal neu starten.
Ich starte den nochmal neu.
Okay, okay, okay.
Escape.
Wird wieder Escape gehämmert.
So, und jetzt gehen wir wieder Boot-Manager.
Und booten vom...
Achso, kann ich jetzt schon von der Platte booten?
Wie ist das denn jetzt eigentlich?
Hat das jetzt funktioniert mit dem Insta?
Muss ich jetzt nochmal?
Ja.
Hat er jetzt schon installiert und ich kann von der Micro-SD-Karte booten?
Dann können wir mal ausprobieren.
Also SSD...
Das da?
Nee.
Ich habe nur den Installer geladen.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt sicherstellen, was der nimmt beim Installer?
Aber das kann ich dann auswählen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Okay, dann laden wir den Installer jetzt nochmal.
Ach, Moment!
Jetzt habe ich es kapiert, was der Dude gemacht hat.
Nee, das machen wir auch.
Das machen wir auch.
Sonst bräuchte ich ja noch eine SSD.
Oder?
Also wenn ich jetzt den Installer boote und sage im Installer, ich wähle meine SSD aus, dann kann ich doch nicht auf der gleichen SSD VMware installieren und gleichzeitig Datastore machen.
Das heißt, ich muss das so machen, was der Typ hier auch gemacht hat.
Sehe ich das richtig, ja?
Exit.
Okay, also was muss man drücken?
Shift-O.
Kann man da einfach so neu starten?
Ctrl-Alt-Enf oder so?
Nope.
Pogo! Pogo, Leute! Pogo in den Chat, genau.
Shift-O-Mega-Lull.
Vmfs-Datastore installieren auf das gleiche Menü ist immer mühsam.
Naja, aber ich...
kann doch nicht... ähm...
Nee, nee, nee, machen wir nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, machen wir ja nicht.
Wir machen... wir machen Installation auf die Micro-SD-Karte und Datastore auf die externe SSD.
Aber damit man das machen kann, muss ich doch diese komische Option eingeben beim Booten.
Wenn ich den Kerl im Video richtig verstanden habe.
Weil ansonsten kann ich jetzt hier nicht die SD-Karte auswählen.
Oder doch?
Enter.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Accept and continue.
Jawoll, die ULA.
Der erkennt meine Micro-SD-Karte nicht.
Guck, jetzt kann ich das nur...
Das ist mein USB-Stick.
Das ist die... das ist die... ähm...
Deswegen hat der Typ das gemacht mit dem... mit dem...
Das mach ich jetzt nochmal.
Wie kann man... wie kann man rebooten?
Bei Canceling installation will ich rebooten hier selber. Yes!
Boah, das ist nicht... nicht so... nicht so einfach.
Ja.
Reboot.
Du darfst rebooten.
Ist erlaubt.
So.
Escape hammern.
Was war das?
Shift...
Shift-Pog-O.
Ne?
Weil ich drücken muss.
Okay.
Boot-Manager.
Von...
Flash.
Shift-O.
Okay.
Runweasel.
Was zum...
Geil.
Runweasel.
Ist das nicht was uraltes RedHat-mäßiges?
Okay.
Was?
CD-ROM-Boot.
Haben wir?
Ja.
Auto.
Partition.
OS.
Data.
Size.
Oh.
Ami-Tastatur.
Acht.
Eins.
Neun.
Zwei.
Habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben?
Lass...
Lass mal kurz überprüfen, ob ich da jetzt kein Mist geschrieben habe.
Okay.
So.
Buch Eagles.
So Quick.
So.
...
interests.
Und wenn ich aber sagen kann, ich dass ich das nicht geschrieben habe.
Auto.
Partition.
Pa-ti-tion.
OS.
Data.
Eigentlich müsste der Chat jetzt schreiben He doesn't know oder irgendwie sowas.
Dass ich mich verschrieben habe.
Obwohl ich mich nicht verschrieben habe.
Datasize.
Acht.
Eins.
Okay Enter.
Ich habe keinen zweiten USB-Stick hier gerade.
Das ist wirklich grad' ziemlich...
Ähm.
Darf ich sagen?
Ziemlich knapp.
So.
ich hoffe der bietet mir jetzt meine micro sd karte an zum zum installieren moment der zeigt
nur zwei sachen an okay ich blicke nicht durch
moment man kann das gar nicht auf die micro sd karte installieren sich das richtig der
unterstützt ihm der esx unterstützt die micro sd karte gar nicht die micro sd karte ist rein
zum booten da ich glaube jetzt habe ich das kapiert die micro sd karte braucht man überhaupt
nicht also nur zum uefi boot weil uefi boot ohne micro sd karte wahrscheinlich nicht geht okay dann
könnte man da eigentlich auch eine 512 mb oder 512 mb oder 512 mb oder 512 mb oder 512 mb oder
irgendwie was total furz kleines an micro sd karte nehmen gewähren der boot guckt das was
er jetzt immer ssd okay easy übrigens mein chat ist gerade tot entweder hat keiner was
geschrieben oder ist abgekackt es gibt doch ein bootloader ist erlaubt von stick oder ssd zu booten
ohne sd karte der für raspberry pi an sich ja ja gibt es aber ich weiß nicht ob das uefi boot mäßig funktioniert
ach nee du meinst für esx oder was also für raspberry pi selbst funktioniert ohne probleme das
habe ich schon ausprobiert accept and continue okay das ist die ssd uefi selected ja ja okay
default keyboard layout swiss german kann man es nicht einfach einfach in german machen root
passwort 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 bestes passwort ach 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 8 9 exzellent jetzt geht das wieder los 1 2 3 4 5 6 a underscore 1 2 3 4 5 a underscore
what you got debated okay also okay was was machen wir da jetzt also was was war okay also machen wir
cute chat 1 2 3 jeweils jeweils das c groß cute chat 1 2 3 ja gott sei dank wenigstens geht das
der installer will repartition was weiß ich ob das die richtige disk ist ich sage jetzt einfach ja
also okay mach okay gucken wir mal nebenbei ob der hier noch irgendwas zu erzählen hat
ist der first boot and successful i mean to a point because i do not have a network cable
connected to it so it doesn't give browser hadoop start control any your own cluster computing nice
video sehr gutes video viel besser als diese kack vor allem anleitung wie greifst du die konsole vom
raspberry pi auf dem desktop mit der capture card da hatten wir eben auch so unsere probleme drin
okay has been installed successfully evaluation mode ist es nicht kostenlos ich dachte es ist
kostenlos da der kram kostet mittlerweile nichts mehr musst du trotzdem registrieren und wo gibt
man den key ein ja ich kann mich ja mit dem fake account registrieren so ob kein problem wie es
für web client gibt man den ein und dann muss man reinstallen ach nee die wollen wir sagen wenn ich
weiter evaluieren will muss ich weiter evaluieren muss ich weiter evaluieren muss ich weiter evaluieren muss ich
reinstallen okay ich mache ein usb stick raus
der raspberry pi der schmilzt sich gleich unten drunter durch
der ist am schwitzen
und nicht in der black ops beta sondern wortwörtlich so gut restart alles klar
so mal gucken ob der jetzt richtig bootet warum macht der warum macht der
warum macht der
warum macht der pxe ihr soll von meiner ssd LookUp
PXE
boot order falsch wahrscheinlich bootorder fallen es geht
bootorder contributed
bootorder fields
bootorder related
noodle
ood
But I need you
Tomb idle
ich habe es kapiert
zwischen
primeiro
immer wenn dieses boot zeug kaputt ist dachte gerade der raspberry pi wenn wir halt verreckt
ist ist ist das da meine ssd das meine ssd das meine ssd anscheinend anscheinend ist das meine
ssd toller name oder 2018 12 05 bester name für eine ssd jetzt weiß ich auch warum der vor
immer zertifizierung machen muss der installer an sich die ganze geschichte ich war so kompliziert
dass er dafür erst mal fünf vor immer schulung besuchen muss und da kann man eigentlich kann
man jetzt nicht sagen der installer selbst war eigentlich kein problem der ganze ganze
raspberry pi geschichte drumherum war krampf
aber der installer an sich war nur wirklich einfach du konntest eigentlich außer außer
disk auswählen konnte nichts machen so also die boot geschwindigkeit ist jetzt nicht gerade die
die mich von den socken haut aber hier erwartet das jetzt auch gar nicht auf dem raspberry pi
es gab da gab es früher vor irgendwie 15 jahren nicht noch den gsx server ich habe das irgendwie
im hinterkopf es gab es gab doch auch mal einen gsx server das war quasi vor allem weil
ich eine workstation für windows server so was in der richtung haben sie aber eingestellt
als glaube ich keine keinen mensch gejuckt da sind wir doch und die hatten auch mal die hatten nicht
nur den gsx aber die hatten auch mal so einen so einen kostenlosen windows server virtualisierungs
ding aber das gab es auch nur eine version von irgendwie so okay ich ziehe mal die tastatur ab
und dann gehen wir mal da per webinterface drauf und gucken ob es funktioniert
sorry falls ich irgendwelche subs übersehen habe das war keine absicht ich habe es einfach im chat nicht mitgekickt
während ich hier rum basteln war so da sind wir anyprimers also 192.1.3.6 alles klar 2.1.3.6
ja kein problem wir accepten das was sind wir
gsxlogi
sehr schön was ist der fall ist es root oder ist es admin oder was ist das
chat 123
das ist ja nice
fast runtergeschmissen
ok nice
warum ist das das alte zeug wie sieht das neue zeug aus ich leute ich kann mich noch nicht
dran erinnern von ein paar jahren da hatte vor allem war noch ein flash da
musst du noch flash installieren für das webfrontend das war aber nicht er data store was wie non ssd
natürlich ist es eine ssd aber usb ssd deswegen kapiert dass wahrscheinlich nicht data store
browser doch das ist noch gar nicht so lange her wo wir wirklich auf der arbeit noch flash
verwenden mussten um den krams zu administrieren beziehungsweise wir haben sie nicht wie ein paar
linux kisten drauf angelegt flash interface da richtig hässlich aus
hallo darf keine bilder mehr anklicken doch ein browser leckt wir sehen was ich
mich der frage warum haben wir diesen windows warum haben die diesen windows
klein eigentlich diesen wie es für klein oder was es damals gab eigentlich
abgeschafft ich fand diese windows klein auch wenn ich kein großer windows fan
bin ich fand ihn gar nicht so übel das hat finde ich besser funktionieren
als im browser ok also wie liegt man jetzt hier zeug an ich habe keinen plan
von von vom esx hier create register vm brand new virtual machine next ok wir
sind mal ganz wir mal wieder luft sagen wir machen an ubuntu server drauf erst
mal und dann windows und dann probieren wir abend windows aus er zeigt nicht den
echten inhalt an
ok
ja warum nicht download ubuntu server vor arm ja genau den was 20 mal ist es
schon raus das schon raus ich dachte es kommt erst nächste woche oder so kommt
ja auch das nächste woche die haben sich einfach gedacht kommt die drei tage
vorher kann man kann man schon mal kann man schon mal machen crew wie live server
übrigens ubuntu 20.10 ist das harambe release
das heißt irgendwas crew wie gorilla ich bin ja dafür die hätten das kunden der
ausnahmsweise codename harambe machen sollen
fix out ok warum lade ich das übrigens hier runter ist eigentlich total sinnlos
so gut also ist er immer wo sie mal installieren wir mal einen server und
installieren wir mal einen server und installieren wir mal einen server und
data
also wo und größt Compatibility wunderbar os family linux windows kann man
die isos hochladen während man in dem anlegendialog ist oder muss man die
vorher irgendwo laden isos während man in dem anlegen dialog ist oder muss man
die vorher irgendwo laden kannst später als cd mounted was per ssh drauf kopieren
ja wunderbar us family linux kinders detention en costsANT latte windows hard tribute
ok also cpu ja mal eine 512 reicht auch erstmal mal so viel 16 g reicht auch ja alles klar
wunderbar next moment wir machen noch mal den usb controller weg den braucht keiner data store
ubuntu finish da ist es so und wo lädt man jetzt isos hoch data store kann man als isos
isos einfach hochladen oder wo lädt man isos hoch das vm edit ok big brain und dann wahrscheinlich
cd data store iso fall ach so ok und da upload aha verstehe ubuntu nein groovy groovy
uploadet er jetzt wo sehe ich denn wie weit damit uploaden ist ach da oben high speed das
ist ja wahnsinnig schnell wenn es zu singen max ich habe es mal ausprobiert ich verwende
das aktuell nicht aktiv das ist ja eine mega schnelle upload der übrigens nicht an der ssd
liegen kann weil die ssd ist ziemlich ziemlich zackig
ja
mmh
und es wird wahrscheinlich an der netzwerksgeschichte liegen
Ubuntu Founder ja
und dann mach ein ls via ssh
ist ein ssh standardmäßig an
ssh
ne das musst du wahrscheinlich erst einschalten
ok da sind 3 dateien drin sehe ich
neinn
hat das jetzt abgebrochen
ist es jetzt
das abgebrochen
wisst ihr was ich kopiere das per scp drauf das gibt bestimmt auch
ich kopiere das per scp drauf
kopiere es per scp drauf wie läuft noch nein wie es jetzt ist aber weg spätestens jetzt ist
weg jetzt habe ich gelöscht wo mache ich denn wo mache ich den ssh an wo könnte man also als
esx nur wo könnte man es machen haust haust manager eine güte services und dann ssh in den
services dann bin ich drin das gibt aber kein ssh tsm ssh die müssen auch alles anders nennen
oder start tsm ist für mich so einen so einen tape
backup gedöns aber als root weißt du was keck keck w
qt chat 123 underscore qt chat 123 underscore
mit was lockt man sich denn da ein jetzt qt chat 123
a0 qt chat 123 nicht underscore
ja
Ah ja.
So, und jetzt kann man da...
Und wo bin ich da jetzt unterwegs?
Store?
Ah, ne.
Was?
CD, VM, V...
Volumes.
Data Store 1.
Aha.
So, und da gucken wir mal unter Ubuntu.
Tatsächlich, da sind andere Sachen drin.
Okay.
Vor allem, ich hinterfrag das gar nicht.
Und wo kopiere ich jetzt ein ISO hin?
Einfach hier rein.
Einfach hier so hin.
Ja.
Achso.
Okay, MKDI.
Irgendwie Images oder so.
So, und dann kopieren wir den Krams nämlich einfach da hin.
SCP, Download.
Harambe.
ISO.
Nach Pi...
Ne, warte mal.
Root at 4.
Und zwar dahin.
Images.
Bam.
Cute Chat.
1, 2, 3.
Okay, das geht irgendwie schneller als über das Webinterface.
Oder kommt...
Kommt...
Ah, vielleicht.
Vielleicht ist da gar kein großer Unterschied.
10 MB die Sekunde?
Aber ganz schön langsam.
Ich meine, das ist Gigabit auf eine SSD.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das geht nicht auf die SD-Karte.
Das geht auf die...
Das geht auf...
Ah, Moment.
Moment.
Wo habe ich die SSD dran gehängt?
Habe ich die SSD vielleicht an USB 2.0 gehängt?
Ah.
Ich habe die SSD an USB 2.0 gehängt.
Exzellent.
Kann man das ausschalten und wieder einschalten?
Einfach ausschalten und wieder einschalten und umhängen die SSD.
Oder kann man das vielleicht sogar im laufenden Betrieb umhängen?
Geht das?
So im laufenden Betrieb?
Soll ich mal ausprobieren?
Das probieren wir jetzt mal.
Ach so, ja, ja, das Boot...
Ach ja, stimmt.
Aber ich kann es doch jetzt an USB 3.0 hängen und dann rebooten und dann davon booten, oder?
Das müsste doch funktionieren.
Ich probiere das mal.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich es einfach umhänge.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt.
Das kackt ab.
Oder pro kackt es ab.
So, und jetzt?
Oh, jetzt ist RIP.
Leute, jetzt ist vorbei.
Ne, da ist er wieder.
Wie ging das jetzt?
Ihr wollt mir doch nicht erzählen, dass das funktioniert.
Moment.
Ganz saft.
Ah, ne, RIP, vorbei.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Okay.
Was ist denn die offizielle Sache, um einen ESX zu rebooten?
Geht man dann hier auch auf Host?
Ah, hier, Host Reboot.
Ja, ich habe eh nichts laufen.
Ach Mist, nein.
Ich brauche hier die Tastatur wieder.
Das komme ich ja nicht ins Boot-Menü.
Schnell umgestöpselt.
Jetzt warte ich eigentlich nur noch, bis der rebootet.
Wie lange braucht das so zum Rebooten?
Ja, ja, wir stellen das jetzt auch gleich um.
Eventuell reboote der jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr richtig, weil der USB, weil ich USB umgehängt habe.
Wir warten mal kurz, wenn...
Was drückt? F12.
Ach, guck mal da.
Restart in progress.
Pro, progress.
Ich glaube, der mag das nicht, weil ich ihm das...
Ah, doch.
Escape.
Okay.
Boot-Manager.
Ich glaube, man kann das gar nicht umstellen, die Reihenfolge.
Oder?
Raspberry Pi Configuration.
Im Boot-Manager.
Mit Bild hoch, Bild runter vielleicht.
Wow, der ist ja gut.
Der ist ja...
Weg dich ab.
Nee.
Kann man nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt Enter drücke, bootet er.
Man kann das nicht umstellen.
Das ist ja auch von der SD-Karte.
Das ist ja quasi kein Raspberry Pi BIOS.
Der hat ja sowas nicht.
Das läuft ja gerade von der SD-Karte.
Aber vielleicht kann man es im Device-Manager ändern.
Hm.
Display Configuration.
Ah, das ist ja glaube ich...
Das ist den Mist, den wir vorhin umgestellt haben.
So, Advanced Configuration.
Nope.
Was?
Use the Boot Options in Raspberry Config.
Ja, das können wir ja nicht machen.
Haben wir ja nicht.
Wir haben keinen Raspberry Config hier drauf.
Gibt's nicht.
Aber der könnte es ja zumindest mal auf der SD-Karte updaten.
Nee, also anscheinend kann man die Boot-Reihenfolge nicht ändern.
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Ich übertakte den.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich übertakte den Raspberry Pi.
Nee, nee, mach ich nicht.
Das Ding ist eh schon übelst heiß gerade.
Secure Boot...
Nee, Const...
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Gibt's nicht.
Man kann die Boot-Reihenfolge nicht ändern.
Was ist denn Boot Maintenance Manager?
Meine Güte, ist das versteckt.
Boot Maintenance Manager.
What the fuck?
Und jetzt?
Change Order.
Okay.
Das da.
Äh.
Plus.
Wo soll ich drücken?
Boah, ey.
Das musst du ja fast schon studieren, das.
Das ist ja...
Das ist das, was du da durchblickst.
So, hat er es jetzt kapiert?
Nee.
What?
Ich hab das doch gerade hochgemacht.
Enter.
Okay.
Commit Changes.
Okay, ich reboote mal und wir gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat.
Boot Order.
Meinst du, das hat er nicht gespeichert?
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, ob er es gespeichert hat.
So, Boot Maintenance Manager.
Boot Options.
Boot Order.
Alter.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Zack.
Enter.
Jetzt muss ich aber erstmal sagen...
Ach nee, F10 Save.
Yes.
Set.
Warum gibt es ein Commit Changes und Exit?
Aber jetzt hat er es kapiert.
Okay.
Jetzt müsst ihr ja booten von der SSD.
Schauen wir mal.
Da kann ich nämlich die Tastatur endlich wieder abmachen.
Und? Postchamp? Postchamp?
Nein.
Wo ist das Problem?
What the fuck?
Also, mehr als umstellen und saven konnte ich doch wirklich nicht.
Natürlich habe ich gespeichert.
Ich habe fünfmal gespeichert.
Okay, wo ist das Problem?
Raspberry Pi.
Ich habe Save und Commit gemacht.
Ich habe alles, alles gemacht.
Ich glaube, ich habe es falsch rum gemacht.
Ich muss bestimmt committen.
Committen und dann saven.
Was jetzt?
Monkers.
Okay.
Also.
Boot Maintenance Manager.
Boot Options.
Boot Order.
Das ist ja...
Alter, ich habe mega Verzögerung gerade.
Noch mehr als sonst.
Okay, zack.
Jetzt geben wir mal das Ganze nach oben.
Escape.
Commit.
Scheint äußerst komplex zu sein, das Ganze.
Stimmt, ich muss Enter drücken.
Ich darf nicht Escape drücken.
So.
What the...
Raspberry Pi, please.
Enter.
Ha?
Ah, yes.
Okay.
Jetzt Commit.
Und dann Save.
Nee, erst mal Commit.
Erst mal Commit.
Oder...
Das...
Anders habe ich es eben gemacht.
So, guck, es ist oben.
Guck...
Und jetzt mache ich F10 Save.
Yes.
So, und wenn es jetzt nicht geht,
dann...
ist was kaputt.
Also, mehr geht ja nicht.
Also, mehr können wir jetzt wirklich nicht machen.
Okay, das will nicht.
Hahaha.
Dann...
Dann booten wir jetzt von Hand.
Ist okay.
Ich boote von Hand von der SSD nochmal.
Was?
Wie?
Nee.
What the fuck?
Alter.
Okay, Moment.
Ich muss gerade mal Elgato, Elgato-Zeug neu starten.
Das ist gerade total am Rumspacken.
Ähm...
Schnensch, wenn du noch gar nichts hast, sind die Bundles gar nicht verkehrt.
Weil...
Da ist ein Netzteil dabei.
Und...
Gerade der Raspberry Pi 4
ist nicht so...
Nicht so toll, wenn du den über USB von irgendeinem Rechner oder so betreibst.
Das offizielle Raspberry Pi-Netzteil ist da schon ganz gut.
Den Rest brauchst...
Also, das Gehäuse brauchst du nicht wirklich.
Also, was ich dir für den Raspberry Pi 4 empfehlen würde, ist...
Ähm...
Das offizielle...
Das offizielle Netzteil zu nehmen.
Oder halt irgendwie ein anderes...
Was ist das?
5 Volt, 3 Ampere Netzteil oder so.
Aber das offizielle ist ganz gut.
Ähm...
Was sicherlich gerade für den Raspberry Pi 4 nicht verkehrt ist,
sind ein paar Passivkühler.
Oder eben...
Einen reichenden Gehäuse dabei.
Mit...
Ähm...
Mit Kühlkörper.
Also, wenn du den ein bisschen verwenden willst,
dann kauf dir einen Raspberry Pi 4 und die...
Und...
Und eins von diesen...
Ähm...
Ich hab jetzt vergessen, wie es heißt.
Diese Metallgehäuse.
Die sind ganz gut.
Aber du kannst...
Du kannst...
Aber wenn du einfach nur einsteigen willst,
ist das Bundle nicht verkehrt.
Da ist ne...
Zwar keine gute, aber ne brauchbare...
SD-Karte dabei.
Ähm...
Netzteil...
So ein...
Das offizielle Gehäuse.
Das ist...
Das ist nicht sonderlich geil.
Also 100 Euro für...
Ja doch, der Raspberry Pi 4 ist...
Äh...
Relativ teuer, ja.
Weil früher haben die Bundles irgendwas um 50 Euro gekostet oder so.
Okay, jetzt kann ich die Tastatur wieder...
Ich guck mal...
Gerade...
Ups.
Ich guck mal gerade, ob es ein ordentliches Bundle gibt, während das bootet.
Also ich kauf meine Sachen entweder da...
Oder da...
Oder im...
Bei Amazon.
Muss man mal gucken.
So.
Pi 4 Bundle.
Was gibt's da?
Was Gescheites?
Was hast du?
Knärbeer hat was gepostet.
Alter, 160 Euro!
Das ist aber schon ein bisschen viel.
Das ist aber ein bisschen...
Das ist ein bisschen teuer.
Zumal das Gehäuse...
Ist das...
Taugt das Gehäuse wenigstens?
Ah, das ist...
Das ist ein aktiv gekühltes Gehäuse.
Okay.
Na, also das ist ein bisschen teuer.
Das ist ein bisschen teuer.
Ich mein, guck dir mal.
Für 160 Euro...
Für 160 Euro kriegst du schon einen fertigen Rechner.
Irgendwo fertig von Ebay.
Ach, das ist die 8G-Version.
Okay.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
Die 8G-Version kostet ja alleine schon irgendwie 70 Euro.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Guck mal.
Dann bezahlst du quasi 70 Euro von Raspberry.
Und...
Oder, sag mal so, 80 Euro von Raspberry.
Und noch einmal 80 Euro für eine SD-Karte und ein Gehäuse.
Nee, nee, nee.
Das würd ich nicht machen.
Das ist ein bisschen teuer.
Dann würd ich mir lieber das Gehäuse hier kaufen.
Oder eines der anderen Gehäuse.
Und dann ist auch gut.
Die Dinger sind ganz okay.
Oder das da.
Kauft ihr lieber so ein Case?
Das Case ist wirklich ganz gut.
Wenn man es passiv gekühlt haben will.
Also die Bundle...
Naja, also das ist, glaub ich, kein gescheiter...
Guck mal, ob die hier bessere haben.
Weil, wie gesagt, ich kauf die Sachen meistens hier...
Hier.
Oder...
Starter-Kit.
Ja.
Ja, da kommen wir doch schon eher in sinnvolle Sachen.
Also 8G brauchst du nicht.
Es sei denn, du willst ESX drauf machen.
Das offizielle Case ist nicht sonderlich tolle, muss man sagen.
Ja.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, es ist jetzt...
Das reicht.
Der Raspberry Pi 4 wird halt ziemlich warm.
Deswegen der Raspberry Pi 4...
Das ist der erste.
Beim 1, 2, 3 war das noch nicht das Problem.
Ist so ein Gehäuse hier nicht verkehrt.
Entweder das da.
Oder diese...
Oder davon eins.
Das ist natürlich die Premium-Variante.
Äh...
Ja.
Da kann man aber 16 Euro für ein Gehäuse ausgeben.
Aber hier hast du das offizielle Netzteil dabei.
Ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
By the way, du musst hier sagen, dass du EU-Style-Plug haben willst.
Sonst kriegst du so ein komisches Ding.
Reicht wohl der USB-Anschluss einer Fritzbox für die Stromversorgung.
Also, wenn du den einfach nur anmachen willst und eidel laufen lassen willst,
dann dürfte das gehen.
Aber der wird wahrscheinlich von Anfang an gleich meckern,
dass er Probleme mit der Stromversorgung hat.
Also, der Raspberry Pi, der läuft meistens.
Aber der ist instant am meckern, dass er zu wenig Stromversorgung hat
und kackt dir im Zweifelsfall auch mal ab.
Der kackt dir ab, taktet sich runter, was auch immer.
Also,
das ist ein Problem.
Ich würde sagen,
stabil betreiben kann man es an dem USB-Anschluss von einer Fritzbox nicht.
Das ist nicht umsonst ein 3-Ampere-Netzteil.
Warte mal,
lass mal gucken,
was ist da für ein Netzteil dabei?
Äh,
Power,
Power Supply.
Da steht natürlich nicht dabei,
was es für ein Netzteil ist.
Aber das ist ziemlich sicher ein 3-Ampere-5-Volt-Netzteil,
was hier dabei ist.
Official Pi Power Supply.
Ja gut,
wenn du wirklich eine Magnetfestplatte dran machen willst,
dann reicht es natürlich auf gar keinen Fall.
Aber so,
so eine SSD braucht ja dann auch nicht so viel.
Ja,
Leute,
wie wäre es mit Specifications?
2,5 Ampere.
Ist das jetzt euer Ernst?
Dass es nirgendswo steht?
Hier,
5 Volt,
2,5 Ampere Netzteil.
Also,
wenn du so eins hast,
dann kannst du das natürlich auch nehmen.
Ich glaube,
das ist kein Unterschied zwischen Pi 3 und Pi 4.
Ja doch,
Pi 4 hat USB-C,
genau.
Doch,
dann sitzt,
dann ist es ein 3-Ampere.
5 Volt,
3 Ampere,
gibt es ungefähr 15 Watt.
5,1 Volt.
Hoho.
5,1 Volt,
3 Ampere.
Ja,
also das ist schon,
wenn du den wirklich auch ein bisschen belasten willst,
ist das sinnvolle Sache.
Also,
schau mal hier.
Root,
Qt,
Chat,
1, 2, 3.
Leute,
ich kopiere nochmal,
ich kopiere jetzt nochmal das ISO und wir gucken mal,
wie schnell es jetzt ist.
What?
Nein.
SCP,
da hin.
Hä?
Oh,
da hat sich das nicht gespeichert.
Muss man das jedes Mal neu anmachen,
SSH?
Ah,
okay,
nee,
ich muss wahrscheinlich sagen,
dass der jedes Mal,
dass der auch gestartet bleibt.
Yeah,
start and stop with host.
With host.
Ah,
sehr gut.
So,
ich kopiere jetzt nochmal das ISO.
Kann man,
kann der,
kann der ESX-SSH-Keys?
Ich meine,
da war ja mal ursprünglich ein stinknormales Red Hat drunter.
Ich weiß nicht,
wie es aktuell aussieht.
Du lässt ESX auf einem Pi laufen.
Ja.
Okay,
nee,
SSH-Keys gehen nicht.
Es gibt ein Beta-Projekt seit einer Woche.
So wirklich viel schneller ist es jetzt auch nicht,
ne?
Der Pi limitiert.
Ja,
aber das ist eine Gigabit-Verbindung.
Da sollte der doch mal zumindest,
dass er da 120 MB durchkriegt,
das ist mir schon klar,
aber,
ein bisschen mehr.
Vielleicht wird er zu hart.
Vielleicht wird er zu heiß.
Hat man,
hat man hier dabei,
die,
ups,
die Tools
für
VC,
VC?
Nee,
hat man nicht,
ne?
Man hat keine Raspberry Pi Tools mit dabei,
wo man gucken kann,
wie warm das Ganze wird.
Willst du auch virtualisieren?
Ja,
klar,
deswegen installiere ich das ja.
Aber ich will ausprobieren.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass es wirklich eine sinnvolle Anwendung,
ne,
die Dinger gibt es nicht.
Sind nicht drauf.
Gibt keinen.
Ich drücke hier gerade wie verrückt,
Tab,
gibt es nicht.
VC,
Gen,
CMD,
gibt es nicht.
Ich drücke hier gerade,
ne,
was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Ja,
ich glaube nicht,
dass es so im Heimbereich
super viele Anwendungsszenarien gibt
für einen
Pi ESX.
Aber wofür es halt cool ist,
wenn man ein bisschen üben will damit.
So,
er hat kopiert.
Okay,
also jetzt starten wir mal eine VM.
Zack,
Edit,
Network Adapter,
wobei,
das machen wir später.
Data Store,
ISO,
Images,
Harambe,
Ubuntu,
Connect and Power on,
Safe.
Power on.
So,
mal gucken,
mal gucken.
Konsole?
Hallo?
Meine Tastatur
geht nicht in der Konsole.
Das ist schlecht.
So,
mal gucken,
mal gucken.
Konsole?
Hallo?
Meine Tastatur
geht nicht in der Konsole.
Das ist schlecht.
Warum geht meine Tastatur
nicht in der Konsole?
Das sagt ganz schön.
Wisst ihr was,
wir gehen,
wir machen das Ganze mal
im Chrome.
Das ist Firefox.
Im Chrome geht manchmal
die Sachen besser.
Gut.
Chat.
Eins,
zwei,
drei.
Was ist ESX?
Virtualisierungsplattform.
Du brauchst noch
die
Vmware Remote Console
als Download.
Gibt's die für Linux?
Das ist irgendeine
Wine-Version.
Das ist
irgendwie
eine
Wine-Variante.
Stimmt,
man kann sich
da mit
Workstation drauf
verbinden,
ne?
Oh.
Grip.
Das sieht
für mich
nicht so aus
als
funktioniert's.
Das arme Ubuntu.
Okay,
warte mal.
Ich probier das mal aus.
Vmware Remote Console
für Linux.
Das probieren
wir mal aus.
Ich will einfach mal gucken,
ob das funktioniert.
Vmware Remote Console
für Linux.
Download.
Ach so.
Okay.
Ja,
ja.
Wir machen das da,
wo ich angemeldet bin.
Vmware Remote Console
für Linux.
Äh.
Ad?
Haha.
Clipboard Manager.
Beste.
Der kann doch
bestimmt Spice.
Das glaub ich nicht.
Bundle.
Wie installiert man
das denn?
Wahrscheinlich
einfach ausführen,
ne?
Einfach so.
Ja.
Einfach ausführen.
Ne.
Oh.
Moment.
Was?
Root.
Auch
noch.
Auch noch als
Root.
Press Enter.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Excellent.
Ich agree.
Äh.
Das war
10-Minute-Mail.
Was macht der denn da?
Der soll einfach
eine Remote-Konsole installieren.
Was hast du für
Vmware bezahlen?
Nix.
Ach so.
Für Workstation.
Äh.
Das hab ich mal
irgendwann bei
irgendeiner Weihnachtsaktion
gekriegt.
Ich weiß nicht mal,
was das gekostet hat.
Installation was
successful.
Vmware.
Äh.
Ja.
Super.
Und jetzt?
Aber
unsuccessful.
Unsuccessful.
Ah ja.
Okay.
Das mag er nicht.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Da mach ich doch mit
Vmware Workstation.
Aber
das funktioniert.
Und wie
verbindet man sich
daraus?
Hier.
Connect to Server.
Und jetzt
hier den da.
Ähm.
122.136.
Root.
Chat.
123.
Ah.
Cool.
Da ist es.
So.
Also machen wir mal
hier Neustart.
Ah.
Juckt das überhaupt
nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ne.
Neustart ist ihm
vollkommen egal.
Kann man.
Moment.
Power.
Restart.
Ähm.
Alter meine Tastatur
geht nicht.
Hier auch nicht.
Lul.
He doesn't know.
He lacks critical
information.
Ja.
What the fuck.
Tja.
Hm.
Wow.
MonkaS.
Haben wir
zu wenig RAM?
Haben wir zu wenig RAM?
Okay.
Edit.
Komm.
Wir gehen mal.
1024.
Ein bisschen RAM
haben wir ja noch.
Haben wir das
falsche Image?
falsche Ubuntu
Image?
Kann das sein?
Also erstens
das, dass ich meine
Tastatur nicht
bedient habe.
Und dann
habe ich das
Tastatur nicht bedienen
kann, ist schon mal ganz,
ganz merkwürdig.
Das könnte wirklich an
dem gelöschten USB
liegen.
Das könnte wirklich an
dem gelöschten USB
liegen.
Wahrscheinlich sogar.
Okay.
Warte mal.
Machen wir das nochmal aus.
Kann man das hier auch
löschen?
Nee, oder?
Ah hier.
Okay.
Jetzt probiere ich das
nochmal kurz über das
Web Interface.
Machen wir es dann hier.
Zack.
Lul.
W.
Linux.
Ist das überhaupt sinnvoll,
wenn ich das hier auswähle?
Ich meine, das ist immerhin
so.
Oh.
Sonst war es Linux.
Sneaky Boy.
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Big Brain.
Subscription wieder.
Huge.
Und jetzt installieren wir
gleich noch Windows.
Mal gucken, ob das
funktioniert.
Okay.
Wir lassen einfach mal alles
so wie es ist.
Zack.
Moment.
Data Store.
Images.
Ubuntu.
Zack.
Select.
ARM64.
Das ist doch richtig,
was ich ausgewählt habe,
oder?
Live Server.
ARM64.
Resourcen.
Drei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Subscription.
Um nicht zu sagen,
ein.
Wir lassen mal hier
Default.
Next.
Finish.
So,
gucken, ob es jetzt
funktioniert.
Nein,
du kannst keine andere
Architektur
virtualisieren.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also,
ich kann kein 64,
AMD 64 Ubuntu
nehmen auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Also,
wenn du Sachen
virtualisierst,
muss die CPU Architektur
unten drunter immer noch
die gleiche sein.
Die CPU ist ja auch
so fast das einzige,
was nicht virtualisiert wird
beim Virtualisieren,
so bescheuert das jetzt klingt.
Ah,
jetzt funktioniert's.
Die CPU wird ja quasi gar,
also,
wird ja gar nicht im
eigentlichen Sinne
virtualisiert.
Was virtualisiert wird,
äh,
sind Ein-Ausgabe-Geräte
und so was.
Image has bogus value.
Ah,
guck mal,
jetzt funktioniert's.
Gibt es Windows für ARM?
Ja,
gibt's,
gibt's.
Habe ich aber noch nie
ausprobiert.
Download Windows Insider
Briefview ARM64.
Der Hype,
der Scam Train ist am Start,
Leute.
Auf,
lasst euch alle schnell scammen.
Windows Insider Briefview ARM64.
Ah!
Och nee,
Microsoft.
Warum muss man sich
überall
für jede Scheiße
anmelden?
Das geht mir so
auf den Sack
mittlerweile.
Windows 10,
Windows 10.
Gab es nicht mal ganz
offiziell einen,
einen ARM Windows?
Guck mal,
das ist ganz neu hier.
Erster Zehnter.
Gibt's da auch,
gibt's da auch irgendwie
einen Download?
Was macht der Installer?
Haha.
Wow.
What the?
What?
Ah,
da ist er.
Englisch.
Habe ich irgendwelche
Subs übersehen?
Hoffe nicht.
Doch.
Äh,
ich glaube,
das ist ein
Windows 10,
äh,
nein?
Okay,
das kann ich nicht
aussprechen.
Fünf ist ja eigentlich
ein S.
Nein?
Waze?
Oder so?
Falls das krasses
Leadspeak ist.
Zumindest
Dankeschön
für 11 Monate.
Excellent
Subscription.
Ende
1,
Ratser 7
verschenkt
5 Abos.
Boah,
jetzt geht's
aber ab hier.
Huge.
Dankeschön
für die ganzen
gegifteten Subs.
Insane-t
Das geht doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht, ohne dass ich eingeloggt bin.
Oh, doch.
Excellent.
Nice.
Was ist das?
Windows 10 Insider Preview, ARM64.
Alles klar.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch den Windows Raspberry Pi.
Es gibt ja irgend so Leute, die das zusammen gewurstet haben.
Ja.
Das gibt es ja auch noch.
Dieses Windows on Raspberry Pi.
Aber wir installieren mal das.
Das muss ja schon irgendeinen Vorteil haben, warum wir das in der VM laufen haben.
Ah, das ist eine, Moment, eine VHDX.
VHDX ist das nicht Hyper-V?
Nee, aber gibt es das auch als ISO?
Ansonsten kann man es bestimmt konvertieren.
Kann man bestimmt konvertieren.
So, also, Layout.
Moment hier, Englisch.
Das eigentliche Layout, was wir haben wollen hier.
Tastaturlayout wollen wir German haben.
No Dead Keys wollen wir haben.
Ja, aber die hat kein GUI.
Die hat, glaube ich, die hat, glaube ich, kein GUI.
Die IoT.
Die Windows IoT Geschichte.
Windows IoT, die gibt es nicht.
Die sind nur.
Oder haben die doch einen?
Beziehen und verwalten.
Microsoft bietet hierzu das nur auf Windows 10 Laufwege.
Microsoft, warum macht ihr das einem so kompliziert?
Windows 10 IoT ISO.
So.
Ich weiß, wir hören jetzt immer die gleiche Musik, aber warum nicht?
Kommen wir mal jetzt hier das da an.
Chip.
Okay, Chip.
Chip ist, Chip ist natürlich wie immer die Seite meines Vertrauens.
Okay, dann gibt es das vielleicht nicht.
Okay, dann laden wir uns das jetzt mal von Chip runter.
Was?
Setup.
What?
Setup-Echse?
What the fuck?
Ich will irgendeinen ISO haben.
Okay, das ist nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ja, was macht eine Installation?
Zeig mal da.
Äh, ja, alles klar.
Done.
Wollen wir nicht.
Jawoll.
Use entire disk.
Done.
Ja, ja, mach mal.
Das ist das Dashboard wahrscheinlich.
Ist nicht so, als wüsste ich, wüsste ich, was es macht.
Name.
Max.
Your server name.
Äh, 0w.
0w.
Das darf man nur klein schreiben, oder was?
Man kann auch Ausnahmen.
Max.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Done.
Na, wenigstens lässt er mich 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 benutzen.
Äh, SSH brauchen wir.
Ach, ne.
Macht er schon, ne?
Was ist Wormhole?
Done.
So, jetzt installiert er.
Sehr gut.
Knärbel, glaube ich nicht.
Du kannst aber einfach dich ausloggen.
Wenn du dich ausloggst, dann geht wahrscheinlich der Download-Link auch nicht mehr.
Hast du dir mal Mikro-Kubernetes angeschaut?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Mach mal ein ESX.
ESX-Top.
Machen wir.
Wir sehen, dass wir nicht viel sehen.
Wir sehen, dass wir...
Was sehen wir denn?
Ah, ja.
Wir sehen, dass man Ubuntu-Dinger macht.
Und Ubuntu installiert.
Ähm, sieht man, wie viele CPUs man hier hat?
Warte mal, sieht man hier N-Proc?
Gibt's das?
Ne.
Cut.
Proc.
CPU-Info.
Ah, cool.
Das geht.
Sehr gut.
4 CPU-Kerne.
Also, halbwegs ist da auch alles erkannt.
So, dem müssen wir jetzt nicht zugucken.
Wenn er da irgendwie Ubuntu-Dings gedönst hält.
Was?
Okay, also Windows kriegen wir, glaube ich, nicht installiert.
Wir finden keine ISO.
Windows on Raspberry Pi.
Da gibt's doch so ein Projekt.
Das hab ich doch letztens erst ISO.
Ich hab den Link gepostet.
Zeig mal.
Wo?
Da.
Excellent.
Das ist aber das ohne GUI, ne?
Ah, cool.
Nice.
Das ist das.
Ne, das ist AMD64.
AMD64 können wir nicht installieren.
AMD64 geht nicht.
Oh man.
Raspberry Pi?
Hä?
Warum heißt das AMD64 und Raspberry Pi?
Den Sinn verstehe ich nicht.
Ne, es scheint schon richtig zu sein.
Aber das verstehe ich trotzdem nicht, weil AMD64 und Raspberry Pi passt irgendwie überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Windows on Raspberry Home.
Genau, das ist das.
Downloads.
Das funktioniert halt überhaupt nicht richtig.
Boah, das ist ja mal wieder voll durch die Brust ins Auge.
Okay, das muss man von Windows 10 ausmachen.
Tja, wir können das ausprobieren.
Ich hab noch ne Windows 10.
Windows 10 Arm-Image.
Und woher krieg ich ne Windows 10 Arm-Image?
Uh, uh, oh ja.
Diese Seiten klingen ja unglaublich vertrauenserweckend.
Kann Herpes-Bläschen komplett verhindern.
Herpes-Bläschen.
Ja, diese Seite sieht äußerst vertrauenserweckend aus.
Das ist ja auch so.
Wo bin ich denn hier jetzt gelandet?
IT-Dienstleister Mainzer.
Aha.
Alter, was?
Und was downloade ich da jetzt?
Die Seite sieht mega morges aus.
Was?
Was zum Teufel muss ich da jetzt downloaden?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das ist, Leute.
Ich hab ehrlich...
Ist ein ISO dabei?
Nein.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich hab wirklich keinen blassen Schimmer.
CMD.
Genau, erstmal ein CMD.
oftmals da fuck alter was okay was auch immer das ist ich will es gar nicht wissen zum glück
war das alles unter windows das sind nur erst die images was sind was sind es die images hier
sollte das ist heute da habe ich im leben und fix von gehört aber ich habe von windows sachen auch
keinen plan okay was muss ich da zu 164 package okay ich habe ernsthaft kein blassen schimmer was
es was es tut was es macht das ist mir zu big brain und dampf klingt auch schon das bestimmt
porn drauf oder so jetzt näher zum glück hat ab 64 latest public release bild ab 64 okay ab 64
jetzt habe ich jetzt auch keine idee was da drin ist ich weiß nicht was da drin ist ich weiß nicht
was da drin ist ich weiß nicht was da drin ist ich weiß nicht was da drin ist ich weiß nicht
jetzt habe ich zu oft geklickt ab 64 habe zu oft geklickt was was was hat was was was
bin ich hier sehend was ist das überhaupt was ich hier sehe download and convert to iso a das
klingt schon mal gut ich mache das jetzt einfach mal ich habe da wirklich keinen blassen schimmer
was es tut create download package jetzt geht's aber auch und hier hallo
nein nein kieb kieb kieb alles klar kieb so wir sind hier unter linux da kann uns das erste mal
ohne weiteres nichts passieren unzip ok ich mach mal einmal hier windows lulwe ich hab wirklich keine
ahnung was ich da gerade mache unzip was exe ah hier ok irgendwelche ich weiß nicht so scharf drauf irgendwelche skripts auszuführen ich weiß nicht so scharf drauf irgendwelche skripte auszuführen ich weiß nicht so scharf drauf irgendwelche skripte auszuführen
bin ich da wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht das ist übersichtlich das sieht nicht so gefährlich aus
ok easy jolo wir führen das jetzt einfach aus also was muss ich installieren aria 2 ja alles klar und
was sonst noch was sonst noch habe ich doch habe ich doch gerade aria 2c aber was sonst noch
kappex was kappextrakt das hört sich an wie irgendwie australische australische superfood wie
sich das holz wie man das heutzutage so schön nennen kennt ihr ich weiß nicht wie ich jetzt
bei diesem namen darauf kommt aber kennt ihr diese werbung wo die wo die dann irgendwie singen
um carlo abo paints champ ich weiß ich keine ahnung wie ich da gerade drauf kommen was was was ist wimmelip
wimmelip was ist wimm was sind wimm files also wimm files chntpw das gibt es alles im arch repo
da bin ich ja froh weil gen iso image gibt es nicht aber aber aber mk iso fs gibt es bestimmt
mk iso
ok wenn es was im arch repo nicht gibt dann stimmt irgendwas nicht okay arch mk iso fs
where is mk iso fs cdr kit alles klar was auch immer ich da gerade mache hey es funktioniert
er downloadet dateien von microsoft macht mir das in iso 3
raus alles klar um carlo abo unaussprechlich aber ausgesprochen gut genau diesen kram meine ich
he doesn't know der lädt jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwelche wie windows hello face migration
alles klar in your face migration ubuntu der ubuntu installer ist fertig bämm erste vor
einmal am start hast recht man könnte mit pacman suchen ja normalerweise habe ich mir dafür eigentlich was installiert was für mich sucht
normalerweise habe ich mir dafür eigentlich was installiert was für mich sucht
also ich hab mir ja ich habe eigentlich einen dings hier installiert
not found oder so und heck www tools ja fein command habe ich eigentlich dafür installiert dass der für mich packman-f macht der eichler der eichler dankeschön für 14 monate wirst du mir nicht glauben aber ich war heute eine stunde eineinhalb stunden im wald unterwegs wandern und irgendwie bin ich drauf gekommen genau ich bin euch
und irgendwie bin ich drauf gekommen genau ich bin euch
und irgendwie bin ich drauf kommen genau ich bin euch
Cool Story, Max.
Kap zu ESD.
Also wenn das funktioniert mit dem ISO, dann beiß ich mir in den Arsch.
Ja, ich war insgesamt sogar drei Stunden draußen.
Eineinhalb Stunden durch den Wald gelaufen, dann war ich essen.
Da gibt es so ein italienisches Restaurant in der Nähe.
Essen, dann bin ich noch zum Auto gelaufen, so eine Viertelstunde.
Dann bin ich wieder heimgefahren.
Der macht da Dinger.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er macht.
Das braucht aber ganz schön viel Platz.
Seit wann hast du ein Auto? Schon lange.
Aber ich fahre eigentlich nie Auto.
So, gucken wir mal, ob Ubuntu gebootet ist.
Failed.
Aber gut, das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Und, und, und, und, und, Postchamp.
Postchamp, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Postchamp.
Auf.
Da bootet es.
Guckt es euch an.
Ein Riesen-Auto.
Richtig, echtes.
Virtualisiert über ESX auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Poggers.
Das ist eine 180-Tage-Trial, ja.
Oh, ist jetzt abgeschissen?
Ne.
Was war es?
2, 1, 4, 5?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
SSH?
Äh.
1, 4, 5?
Ah, tatsächlich.
Ach so, Moment.
Was habe ich für ein Passwort?
Max, Ed.
Äh, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 haben wir gemacht, ja.
Sagst du immer.
Guck mal.
Wir sind auf unserem virtualisierten Ubuntu drauf.
Eine CPU.
Einen CPU-Kern haben wir.
Äh, wir machen mal kurz.
Einen Sus.
Suspensch-CPU.
Weiß ich aus dem Kopf gerade nicht, wie das funktioniert.
CPU-Benchmark.
Ja.
Upt.
Install.
Suspensch.
Das ist Version 7.
Ähm, ja.
Ich glaube, das ist die letzte.
Funktionieren eigentlich alle Pakete auf ARM-Ubuntu.
Die meisten, bestimmt nicht alle.
Also, die, das, das sind eigene Packages, ja.
So, gucken wir mal.
Huge, huge Benchmark.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was sinnvoll ist.
Aber 20.000 Prime, also 20.000 Primzahlen dürften jetzt nicht viel sein.
Ne, sind auch nicht viel.
Ja, nice.
Okay, dann machen wir nochmal was.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal kurz I.O.-Geschwindigkeit von der Platte.
Das dürfte so das eigentliche Problem sein.
Na ja.
Cut.
Def.
Zero.
Ach, PV.
Und dann hier Image irgendwas.
So, mal gucken, wie viel.
Oh, ja.
Ah, ne.
Okay, doch nicht.
Also, Disk-I.O. ist busy durchwachsen.
Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt uns dort einen Firefox drauf installieren.
Okay.
aber ich muss mal kurz was gucken pv sagt wie viel daten gerade durch die
pipe gehen also kannst du wenn du wenn du wenn du
der zero nach pv peps und dann den output in der datei schreibst zeigt er
die halt an wie viel gerade durch das kommando durch geht also pv macht nichts
anderes wir lesen und schreiben und in der zwischenzeit gucken wie viel
durchgeht kannst du mit dd und progress genauso machen aber ich finde es wird pv
ist es am einfachsten da brauchst du viel parameter angeben
wir spielen kranker spielen wir jetzt gleich aus dem snap store auch noch was
ist mit den ubuntu leuten los die wollen jetzt nicht ernsthaft in einem
virtualisierten auf einem raspberry pi mit einem esx in einem virtualisierten
ubuntu jetzt erst einmal den snap store installieren damit sie dann einen snap
container starten können wo dann mein browser drin ist exzellent das ist ja
genau
genau so würde ich es auch machen ich muss minus f1 2 3 4 5 6
so chrome ja weil ich davon ausgehen würde also warum nicht weil ich davon
ausgehen würde dass sachen die über den offiziellen paket manager kommt halt
ganz normale debian packages sind und nicht irgendwelche snaps okay es ist lahm
as fuck guck mal wie lange der chrome schon startet wie unable to open display warum
das display ist da okay das ist bestimmt ein timeout so abt der problem ist dass
mit firefox aus erst mal halbes halbes gnome nach installiert mega upload song
und brennt der raspberry pi schon ich würde ja gerne nachgucken aber kann ich
nicht ich mache mal kurz ich mache mal kurz meine
finger drauf
oh oh älter
älter
ist
das ist heiß
wisst ihr was wir jetzt eigentlich machen müssten jetzt möchte ich einen sp32 holen mit einem
Moment, das ist mein lokaler Firefox.
Ich will meinen lokalen Firefox nicht haben.
Jetzt sofort.
Ich will keinen lokalen Firefox, ich will den Remote Firefox haben.
Der Firefox versucht nämlich manchmal mitzudenken, wenn man einen zweiten Firefox starten will und dann geht das nicht.
So, guck mal, Firefox Remote über den ESX.
Über das virtualisierte Ubuntu ESX.
Warum habe ich einen Kommando?
Warum habe ich einen Kommando für BDO-Locations?
What the fuck?
Warum habe ich sowas?
Also wahnsinnig schnell, wie ihr seht.
Also massive, massive Geschwindigkeit.
Oh, ist das schnell.
Huiuiui, ist das schnell.
High Speed.
Nein, ich kann das auf meinem Raspberry Pi nicht auslesen, weil ich habe da einen ESX drauf installiert.
Und der ESX hat diese ganzen Kommandos nicht dabei.
Das geht ja sehr schnell.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man auf dem ESX...
Kann man auf dem ESX Packages nachinstallieren?
Nee, oder?
Also ich kann doch jetzt sicherlich nicht sagen...
Doch, Top gibt's.
Äh, ESX Top gibt's.
Wir können ja mal hier danach suchen.
Pi ESX-IVC-Gen-CMD.
Das müssen wir aber auf eine Woche stellen.
Virtuality Ghetto.
Oh, was?
Das ist bestimmt eine VMware-Seite.
Nee, das gibt's da nicht drauf.
Okay, Leute.
Das wird nix.
Huge Geschwindigkeit angesagt hier.
Massive Geschwindigkeit.
Also Remote SSH Weiterleitung, virtualisierten Browser, das Spiel starten, das funktioniert nicht.
Aber wir können alternativ mal auf mein YouTube gehen.
Und gucken, ob das auch nur ansatzweise mit mehr als 2 FPS läuft.
Boah, wie das Logo laggt, Alter.
Guck mal, der kann doch nicht mal...
Ah, doch.
Boah, das ist ja so im Arsch.
Oh, Gott.
Ich mach das mal zu.
Nee.
Da geht gar nix.
Da geht einfach gar nix gerade.
Wie ist die Performance bis jetzt?
Wir machen gerade übrigens einen Schwachsinn, wo man die Performance gar nicht bewerten kann.
Also, gut.
Also, ich hab ja bisher nur eine VM laufen und die läuft eigentlich ziemlich brauchbar.
Also, kann sich echt nicht beschweren.
Die VM ist wirklich okay.
Boah, guckt es euch mal an.
Fuck, Alter.
Boah.
Guck mal, die Werbung kackt sogar ab.
Der kann die Werbung nicht anzeigen.
Naja.
Ich mein.
Dafür, dass es ein Raspberry Pi mit ESX ist, darauf ein virtualisiertes Ubuntu und darauf über X-Forwarding ein Firefox laufen.
Dafür ist das doch ganz brauchbar.
Oder?
Also, komm mal, ernsthaft.
Ich kann aber nicht mal die Settings öffnen.
Ich kann aber nicht mal die Settings öffnen, weil jetzt die Thumbnails nachliegt.
Ich glaub, VM Tools gibt es noch gar nicht.
Gibt es VM Tools?
Das können wir gerade mal ausprobieren.
VM Tools.
Actions.
Install VM Tools.
Guck mal hier.
So, dann habt ihr es gesehen.
Wir haben jetzt 720p.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit diesem Display Forwarding, wenn ich auf...
Also, fragt der Skillkiller.
Wenn ich auf meinem Server jetzt X-Forwarding anmache, bleibt dieser virtuelle Monitor auch noch laufen, wenn ich die Sitzung schließe.
Nee.
Du kannst da wahrscheinlich...
Nee, nee, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Es gibt gar keinen virtuellen Monitor.
Der leitet das weiter an deinen lokalen X-Server.
Also, der Monitor ist nicht wirklich virtuell.
So, Achtung.
Hardcore-Variante jetzt.
Disres1337, Dankeschön.
Drei Monate.
Huge Subscription.
Okay, das macht er nicht mit X.
1440p X-Forwarding ist vorbei.
Reap
Browser is leuk.
Browser is pipe freezed.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
ESX Top.
Okay.
Der ist dicht.
Der macht nichts mehr.
Der brennt gleich durch.
Okay, ich mache mal zu.
Ich glaube, da kommen wir jetzt gar nicht weit.
Ooh Mist.
Dann habe ich mein ISO Genesis.
ISO Generator.
Weg damit. Moment, ich habe doch hier mein ISO gerade generiert. Wo war denn das jetzt?
Windows 0w?
Da, hier. Windows Professional AM64 ISO. Bäm. SCP.
Auf geht's. Installieren wir Windows. Jetzt installieren wir Windows auf dem Raspberry.
Jetzt geht's rund. Okay, erstmal 5 Stunden warten, bis es rüber kopiert ist, das ISO.
Na, geht doch. SCP kopiert Sachen über SSH.
So, was könnten wir da auf dem virtualisierten Oboe nochmal kurz ausführen?
Also, ich finde, das läuft wirklich ausgesprochen, das läuft echt ausgesprochen geschmeidig bisher.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Ich habe GPU Benchmark gerade gemacht, Susbench habe ich gerade gemacht.
Das Ergebnis ist halt schlecht.
Aber man kann, also die Unterschiede zwischen...
Susbench in der VM und Susbench auf dem Raspberry selbst sind, glaube ich, vielleicht mal 5%, wenn es hochkommt.
Beim Virtualisieren ist ja der Unterschied zwischen CPU und Host und CPU VM nicht.
Man muss, also I.O. ist halt schlecht.
Habe ich schon ausprobiert. I.O. sagt...
CPU Performance ist, glaube ich, ganz okay.
Kannst du dir mal auf dem Host... Ah, das ist eine gute Idee, das können wir ausprobieren, falls er diese Sorte an Devices überhaupt hat.
Cut, was? Was brauchen wir?
Sys?
Gibt es hier gar nicht.
Gibt es gar nicht. Nope, keine Chance.
Gibt es nicht.
Moment, was?
Wait a minute.
Warum kann ich...
What?
Hä?
Moment, das ist ein Simling? Ist das ein Simling?
Warum geht... Warum geht...
Cut, Proc, CPU Info, aber Proc ist leer.
Was für ein I3? Das ist I3 Status...
Rust heißt das.
Hardware Sensors, das können wir auch...
Monitor...
Ah, Ubuntu, geh mal weg.
Oh!
CPU gelöscht.
Habe ich nicht vertippt.
Cut, Chat, 1, 2, 3.
Wo ist das Problem?
Hallo?
ESX?
Skillkiller?
Du kannst, wenn ein Browser reicht...
Browser zu automatisieren ist ziemlich easy.
Aber Skillkiller, das geht. Du kannst mit VNC, kannst das machen.
Kannst in VNC starten, dann läuft ja quasi die ganze Display Session bei dir auf dem Server und kannst dich connecten per VNC.
per vnc zugucken und sich wieder disconnecten per vnc und du kannst ja auch du kannst es auch per
keine ahnung desktop auf dem linux machen aber ich würde es per vnc machen das geht vnc starten
kannst dich connecten per vnc dort was starten du gehst wieder raus und dann läuft es weiter
so monitor cpu cpu hardware system sensors nein you may need to install wie macht man das
grelax du musst manchmal wenn sich ffz aktualisiert musste in den settings wieder die
better twitch tv emotes geschichten aktivieren aber von xtogo kann man sich nicht ordentlich
attachen oder detachen meine ich detachen
schon mal über eine twitch telegram gruppe nachgedacht wozu könnte aber einfach immer
ein discord kommen exzellent wie installiere ich hier sachen aus gar nicht wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich gar nicht okay hat er hat er windows geploadet ach so ne matthew dann haben
wir dann geht das wahrscheinlich nicht so hat er jetzt das iso abgeladen jawohl okay jetzt
installieren wir eine windows vm jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt create new virtual machine
windows windows ja das trifft es noch am ehesten ja standard cpu zwei stö- nee nee nee so viel
ram haben wir nicht 4000 das muss reichen und ich muss die ubuntu vm ausmachen alles klar dd iso windows
ist schon fertig okay also wir machen das erstmal ob das ubuntu iso wieder aus moment wo ist meine
windows vm hin warum ist sie da nicht drunter und nur da drunter okay also starten wir mal die windows
vm null das klappt im leben nicht äh ist die gecrashed die gerade gecrashed oder so chat wer von euch ist es wer von euch ist es another user
Ja, okay
Die VM crasht
Die startet nicht
1G
Doch kein Arm-Image
Ne, also zumindest starten müsste Windows eigentlich
Also, also die VM
Die VM sollte nicht gleich abkacken
Ne, keine Chance, das klappt nicht
Ja, ich hab das ISO-File selected
Aber zumindest sagen, dass er nicht booten kann
Müsste er ja, ne
Also ich mach jetzt mal das ISO raus
Wenn ich das ISO raus
Ach ne, ist not connected, okay
Aber selbst dann sollte er nicht einfach ausgehen
Sondern einfach im Bootmanager hängen bleiben
Ne
RIP, vergiss es
Da startet nix
Kann man die vielleicht noch anderweitig anlegen
Die Ubuntu-VM ist nicht mehr an
Ne, die hab ich ausgemacht
Okay, man muss sagen, was es ist
Achso, lol
Pogu
Ne
Server
Ja, das Windows-Server ist es, ganz klar
Aber sonst
Ich, 20
Ich stell jetzt mal nix ein hier
Ich starte die jetzt einfach mal
Und guck, ob die prinzipiell bootet
Erstmal Pogu
Pogu starten
Aha
Guck mal, Pogu startet
Bin begeistert
Und jetzt
Datastore ISO
Windows
Ah
Ne, der crasht, wenn er von dem ISO booten will
Der kackt ab, wenn er von dem ISO booten will
Tja, ne, dann nicht
Ja, wir könnten aber was anderes machen
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht deleten, nicht deleten
Wir könnten aber was anderes machen
Wir könnten ihm nochmal sagen
Weg hier damit
Jetzt sollte er zumindest soweit starten, dass er wieder bootet
Genau
Und jetzt kann man ihm hier doch was attachen, oder?
Geht das nicht?
Warte mal, kann man dem jetzt hier nicht sagen attach ISO?
Oder send, send, control alt env oder sowas?
Control alt delete?
Ok, und jetzt, und jetzt mounten wir hier irgendein ISO
Wie mountet man, wie mountet man ein ISO vom Client jetzt?
Edit
Das ISO ist hier drauf, ja
Auf dem Raspberry Pi
Äh, ich habe vergessen, Moment, wo ging das jetzt nochmal?
Send
Ah, eben hatte ich es doch
Send keys, wo?
Ah hier, gestern
Ah, nein
Nein, Leute, keine Chance, der crasht
Der crasht instant, sobald er das ISO bootet
Keine Chance
Feels bad, grip
Ja, nun gut, für was ist es gut, das ganze Ding?
Ehrlich gesagt zu nicht viel
Außer man möchte ein paar Linux-Dinger virtualisieren bei sich daheim
Äh, diese Konsole ist wirklich massive Schrott
Ähm, aber zum ausprobieren und ein bisschen üben damit ist es glaube ich ganz gut
Also wirklich richtig gut gebrauchen kann man das ehrlich gesagt nicht
Gibt es eigentlich Proxmox für ein Pi?
Ne, oder? Das geht nicht
Was im Ordner der VMs gibt es?
Ok
Also gehen wir mal
War das CD?
V
Things
Volumes, Datastore 1
Pogo
Und da gibt es nun was?
VM Kernel Log
VMware Log
Oh, Message Panel
Oh, das ist schlecht
CPU Panel klingt nicht gut
Ne
Das klingt eher nach Monka Smoke
Das wird nichts mit Windows da drauf
Kann man knicken
Aber die Ubuntu VM läuft wirklich erstaunlich, erstaunlich gut
Ich kann übrigens mal diesen ganzen Müll hier wieder löschen
Den ganzen Scheiß wieder weg
Guck mal, das braucht so viel Platz hier
Xen gibt es jetzt auch für den Raspberry Pi, ja richtig
Wie viel Platz haben wir denn insgesamt auf der Rootpaddel?
Ich habe 73 G used?
Für was denn das?
Für was habe ich 73 GB used?
Windows IOT, ja wenn du den ISO findest, dann machen wir das
Also wir haben es gerade probiert
Das hat nicht so ganz funktioniert
Downloads
Defaults?
Was zum?
Sag mal, ist das mein Chrome Ordner, der so viel braucht?
Das ist mein Default Chrome Profil, was 11 GB braucht, sehe ich das richtig?
Ja
Ganz schön viel
Ok, das können wir wieder löschen
Arambe Server
Weg
Ubuntu Server, Proxmox, alles fort
Let's Game
Ach, das war die Schriftgenerierung für das ESP Projekt hier
Können wir Master
Diskstation
Diskstation File
Ja aber trotzdem, warum ist denn immer noch so viel, so wenig Platz auf der Festplatte?
Ne, brauchst du nicht
Kannst du einfach was posten
Aber wie gesagt, wir haben uns vorher schwer getan, ein ordentliches ISO zu finden, was man downloaden kann
Windows IOTiert keine grafische Oberfläche
Ne, aber ich fände schon mal ganz gut, wenn ich überhaupt was installieren könnte
Irgendein Windows, mir erstmal vollkommen egal welches
Ne, da brauchen wir einen Microsoft Insider Account, oder?
Also da haben wir glaube ich vorhin schon mal geguckt
Ach guck mal da
Das hatten wir vorhin
Das haben wir gerade ausprobiert
Das geht nicht
Da crasht die 4M, das geht nicht
Genau dieses ISO haben wir eben ausprobiert vor 5 Minuten
Das geht nicht, leider nicht, dann crasht es komplett
Also ich frage mich echt, warum meine Festplatte so voll ist
Nun gut, Leute was können wir nochmal ausprobieren?
Äh, what?
Warum will der neu installieren?
Hä?
Ach, weil ich die
Ich dab, power off, ich hab die CD noch drin
Edit
Wie editiert man hier was?
Warum haben die eigentlich diesen Windows Desktop Client eingestellt?
Diesen Desktop Client Only
Ich meine, das ist ja ganz cool, dass man das jetzt über den VMA Client machen kann
Also in den VMA Workstation Client
Geht nested Virtualization
Oh
Das ist eine gute Frage
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das meinem Raspberry Pi zumuten will
Gucken wir mal
Geht nested Virtualization
Anscheinend
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt noch ausprobieren
Das, wir machen jetzt eine
Wir starten jetzt eine KVMVM Virtualis-
Ach du Kacke
Ja, das machen wir jetzt noch
Das, das probieren wir jetzt noch aus
Okay, ich geb dem aber ein bissl mehr RAM
Ein bissl mehr RAM darf er haben
Aber da war es nested Virtualization
Aber was nested Virtualisieren wollen
Aber man muss sagen
Also Linux Virtualisieren funktioniert erstaunlich
Erstaunlich gut
Hat der Raspberry Pi echt VTX AMV?
Nein
Hat er nicht
Aber ich probier mal was passiert, wenn man es anschaltet
Also zumindest kenn ich nix
Als dass der Raspberry Pi irgendwas in der Richtung hätte
Ups
Oh
Jetzt hab ich Fullscreen gemacht, wie krieg ich das wieder weg?
Ah
Wie krieg ich das wieder weg?
Piss dich, Alte
Geh weg
Wie, wie, wie?
Ah
Easy, ich schalt einfach wieder aus, dann geht's weg
Und jetzt?
Ah
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Ich lock mich einfach wieder aus
Nee, nee, nee
Wie gesagt, CPU-mäßig haben die glaub ich nix
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste
Ah, jetzt geht's hier gut
Okay
Dann machen wir doch mal
Also was
Ich hab nen 16 GB Swap-File
Warum hab ich denn sowas?
Brauch ich doch überhaupt nicht
Ich hab 8G RAM oder so
16G
Ich hab 16 GB RAM in der VM
Da brauch ich doch kein Swap-File
Warum hab ich da nen 16G Swap-File?
Gibt's Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen
Tatsache
Warum hab ich das gemacht?
Hat das irgendeinen tieferen Sinn?
Äh
Nee, wie geht das?
Swap?
Ah
Jetzt haben wir wieder ein bisschen mehr Platz
Ich weiß nicht, hat's ja immer noch 44 GB used
Was immer noch ganz schön viel ist
Ich glaub, es war Default, ein Swap-File zu erstellen, ja
So, wir haben keinen Swap mehr jetzt
Kein Swap, aber ich brauch bei 16 GB RAM auch keinen Swap
Warum hab ich nen Swap-File angelegt im Installer?
Ich kann mich dran erinnern
Ich hab aus irgendwelchen Gründen damals nen Swap angelegt
Das musst du nämlich explizit auswählen
Das musst du nämlich explizit beim Manjaro Installer auswählen
Dass du nen Swap-File haben willst
Der fragt dich
Weil ich hab sonst nirgendswo mehr nen Swap-File
Ich hab auch nen ganzen anderen Kind
Also, seitdem ich, seitdem ich, ähm
Überall 8 GB plus RAM drin hab
Ich hab eigentlich nirgendswo mehr nen Swap-File
So
So, hab ich jetzt Nested Virtualisierung eingeschaltet
Glaub net, ne?
Ja
Das probier wir jetzt nochmal aus
Ey, wenn das geht
Dann beiß ich mir echt den Arsch, wenn das geht
So, also
CPU, ah ne, man muss erst ausschalten
Doch, auch bestimmt gar nicht
Auf meinem Arbeits-Notebook
Ähm, hab ich tatsächlich noch nen Swap-File
Weil das manchmal gefreezed ist
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Und ich hab gedacht, das liegt daran, weil manchmal
Irgendwie ans Limit kommt vom RAM
Und dann Sachen killen muss
War's aber gar nicht
Nee, nee, Swap, also wenn du, wenn du...
Wenn du kein, wenn du kein Swap-File installiert hast
Dann, äh, legt dir auch keins an, wenn RAM ausgeht
Also, bei Windows ist das standardmäßig so
Die haben immer nen Swap-File
Und, äh, die swappen da ja auch manchmal Sachen aus dem RAM raus
Die gar nicht unbedingt das RAM so voll machen
Die haben ja da so gewisse Magic dahinter, wann wie was geswappt wird
Das heißt, das System crasht dann, wenn der RAM ausgeht
Nee
Dann gibt's erstmal eine Runde
OOM-Killer, heißt das
Der, äh, schießt dann
Der beendet dann erstmal
Programme, von denen er denkt
Dass es jetzt sich lohnt
Diese Programme zu beenden, um wieder RAM zu bekommen
Allerdings ist das meistens nicht gut
Weil der Sachen abschießt, wo du nicht unbedingt willst
Also, das System killt dir dann sozusagen
Mehr oder weniger random
Programme, bis es wieder genug RAM hat
Das sollte am besten erstmal mit nem Browser anfangen
Da gibts schon gleich viel RAM frei
Wow, was ist jetzt hier?
Also, Virtualisierung
CPU-Hot-Ad
Oh ja, das brauch ich auf dem Raspberry Pi unbedingt
Nochmal kurz neue CPU auflöten
Das geht im Leben nicht
Safe
Power on
Sind deine Steckdosen von Nui
Nö
Meine Steckdosen, also die, die ich letztens im Stream gezeigt hab
Das waren die hier
Ah, irgendwas mit A
Aber, ich weiß nicht, was das ist
Aber, letztendlich ist das eh alles das gleiche
Also, es ist egal, welche du kaufst
Das ist unter der Haube alles
Alles das da
Ups
Moment
Moment, wo hatten wir es hier
Tasmota
Die da
Unter der Haube sind das alles die hier
Und was ich mir bei Amazon gekauft hab
Waren
Ja, äh
Du siehst, die sehen auch alle gleich aus
Die sehen alle ähnlich aus
Also ich hab
Mir
Das könnten mehr oder weniger auch die gleichen sein
Das ist alles der gleiche Crap unten drunter
Ja, die da
Die hab ich mir gekauft
Aber wie gesagt, das ist alles der gleiche Müll
Skillkiller fragt
Das ist eine gute Frage
Die verwirrt manche Leute
Kann ich dir erklären
Er fragt hier
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen den Signalen
Minus 15 fragt den Prozess
Ob der sich jetzt nicht mal beenden kann
Und minus 9
Macht ihn kaputt
Minus 15 ist Standard bei Kill
Ich wusste jetzt nicht, dass es minus 15 ist
Ehrlich gesagt, aber Kill minus 9 weiß ich
Dass Kill minus 9 wirklich
Killen ist
Also wenn du unter Linux einen Prozess abschießen willst
Und du sagst beispielsweise hier
Sleep sleep 30
So
Wenn wir uns mal die ID raussuchen
Von dem Sleep
Dann kann ich jetzt Prozess ID sagen
Kill 17019
So
Und was jetzt passiert ist
Kill hat Sleep gesagt
Hier beende dich mal
Und Sleep hat gesagt, okay ich beende mich
Wenn man jetzt einen Befehl hat
Der hängt
Der nicht darauf reagiert
Wenn man ihm sagt, er soll sich beenden
Dann muss man sagen, Kill machen
Kill minus 9
Dann muss man sagen
Und was jetzt passiert ist
Terminated
Also sprich
Sleep hat sich mehr oder weniger selbst beendet
Und hier ist es
Und hier wurde wirklich Sleep
Nicht gefragt, ob es sich beenden möchte
Sondern es wurde einfach quasi
Prozess im Kernel beendet
Und RAM freigegeben
Also das hier ist die Hardcore Kill Variante
Wo auch ein Programm keine Chance mehr hat
Irgendwas
Zu machen
Bevor es gekillt wird
Also du kannst zum Beispiel
Kill minus 15
Oder ein normales Kill kannst du abfangen
Du kannst quasi sagen, hallo ich lausche in meinem Programm
Auf dieses Kill Event
Also das Sick Term heißt das glaube ich
Ähm
Und wenn ich das bekomme
Dann schreibe ich noch was auf die Platte
Und beende mich dann
Das kann ich machen
Aber sobald ich einen Kill kriege ist vorbei
Ich habe mich dichtgemacht
So also wie gesagt
Das sind die Steckdosen, die ich mir bestellt habe
Zum Flashen
Allerdings für den Preis nicht kaufen
Lohnt sich nicht
25 Euro Primedaver
Okay, dann verbinden wir uns auf unser Ubuntu
Und gucken
Ob man wirklich da jetzt was virtualisieren kann
Ich glaub es ja nicht
Wie virtualisiert man überhaupt was
Auf einem Raspberry Pi Ubuntu
Da muss man ja irgendwas mit KVM machen
Hab ich noch nie gemacht
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie das geht
Max hast du ein
Ein was?
Ein Daki Makura
Was ist denn das?
Nicht googeln, ne ne ne ich google sowas nicht on stream
Ich google aber jetzt auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
MonkaS, MonkaTos
Ah
Das ist ähm
Ein großes Kissen
Mit irgendwelchen Anime Figuren drauf
Excellent
Ja
Wer hat der Hand ne
Ich hab mal Dark Souls gespielt
Äh ne ne
Komm mal nur zurück, Demon's Souls
Boah
Auf welcher Plattform kam das ursprünglich raus
War das noch die allererste
Ne das war schon die 360 ne
Oder PS3
Ne 360 war es
Oder war es PS3
Ach was weiß ich
Und ich muss euch sagen es war überhaupt nicht mein Fall
Deswegen hab ich Dark Souls dann auch nicht mehr gespielt
Es kommt jetzt ein Remake
Stimmt, ja das hab ich gesehen
Ok wie
Wie startet man ne KVM Kiste
Auf nem Raspberry Pi
Was?
Suse?
Warum um alles in der Welt soll ich Suse?
Die Leute sind manchmal auch nicht mehr ganz dicht
Wer verwendet 2020
Wirklich noch Suse?
Oder noch OpenSuse
LibWirt
Einfach so
Äh da steht es doch
LibWirt
Äh ok
Raspberry Pi
Word Manager
Machen wir es mal damit falls es den gibt
Wow
Ok wir installieren kurz das halbe Internet
Aber man muss schon sagen
Das geht relativ zackig
Obwohl das auf nem Raspberry Pi
Also ne Ubuntu
Virtualisiert über ESX
Auf nem Raspberry Pi ist
Das ist Performance mäßig schon
In Ordnung
Das kann man so lassen
Ja wir haben auch
Wir haben auch ein Kollege auf der Arbeit
Einen der findet äh Suse ganz toll
Ich sag einfach mal mein Fall ist es nicht
Es soll ja jetzt
Letztendlich soll ja jeder verwenden was er will
War eigentlich letztens das Motor Stream
Ja
Wow
Mein Headset Dings
Verlängerung ist gerade runter gefallen
What the fuck
Warum denn das?
Ich glaub es ist kaputt Leute hört ihr mich noch?
Ah jetzt gehts wieder
Ok
Muss mal kurz mein Headset entknoten
Jetzt ok alles wieder gut
Was wer Suse mag
Hat morgen keine Firewall Freischaltung mehr
Ja ist ne gute Idee
Da kannst du dem Manfred gleich die Firewall Freischaltung wegnehmen
Ist nämlich der einzige der mir einfällt
Der OpenSuse bei uns geil findet
Ja das war das Motor Stream
Äh vor
Gestern
War das nicht gestern?
Aber das Wort habe ich gelöscht
Deswegen ist das weg
Das Wort habe ich gelöscht
Ähm das hatte ich auch schon mal
Das ich unter Windows mein Mikrofon nicht aktivieren konnte
Oder keine Anwendung das Mikrofon mehr
Äh benutzen konnte
Weil man irgendwo unter Windows ein Häkchen setzen kann
Das Anwendungen Zugriff auf das Mikrofon erlauben
Irgendwie abgeschaltet wird
Ja den habe ich gelöscht
Den habe ich gelöscht
Ich hab paar mal Sachen gezeigt
Nicht wirklich schlimme Sachen
Aber wo ich die unbedingt will dass man die öffnet
So dass man sich im Wort sich nochmal angucken kann
Also äh äh
Privacy Leak
So
Ok jetzt habe ich Wirt Merge erzählt
Kann ich jetzt hier wirklich irgendwas virtualisiert machen
Über den Raspberry Pi
Ok was
Lib Demon is not running
Gut mache ich jetzt
Lib Wirt
System
Enable
Jawoll
Start
Gehts jetzt
Oho
Ha
Lib Wirt Demon is
Not running warum
Eben
Ich habe ihn doch eben gestartet
Status
Wow
Active
Ja
Dann gehts vielleicht
Ach vielleicht muss ich das
Vielleicht muss ich das als root machen
Ja stimmt stimmt ich muss das als root machen
Wie Rejected
Was soll das
Warum wird hier einfach irgendwas Rejected
Sauerei Anzeige ist raus
Ok was mache ich da jetzt
Ähm
Ok Solution
Won't buy you
Naja
Warum geht das
Ich konnte doch immer Sudo machen mit dem X
Das ist doch eigentlich kein Problem
Ja natürlich ist das wegen X Forwarding
Aber ich brauche ja X Forwarding
Aber das ist eine
Warum geht das nicht
Warum geht das nicht mit Sudo das müsste doch normalerweise gehen
An früher zu
Uhrzeiten wo man das mit Minus X gemacht hat
Da ging das definitiv
Ich habe mal eine ganze Weile
Äh VMs über Wirt Manager
Auf dem Server gewurstet
Wir fragen einfach Stack Overflow
Excellent
Ok
Was auch immer der Typ hier macht
Ich habe keine Ahnung was das treibt
Das machen wir jetzt einfach mal
Aha
Alles klar Magic Cookie
Chat nicht einloggen jetzt
Kann ich auch SU- machen
Wobei vielleicht soll ich mal wirklich Sudo so machen
In dem Fall weiß man nie so genau was mitgenommen wird
Und was nicht
Lul Stack Overflow Leute
Ich sag es euch Stack Overflow
Äh Hallo
Ok so wirklich was gebracht hat es jetzt nicht
So wirklich was gebracht hat es nicht
Ok machen wir was anderes
Ähm
QEMU
KVM
Ne QEMU
System Arm
Ach ne Moin
Wie konnte man nochmal eine QEMU Geschichte starten
Ähm
QEMU
Startet man da was
Wirt Manager Raspberry Pi
Ich habe noch nie was Virtualisiert auf dem Raspberry Pi
OpenSUSE
Nein warum
Was wollen die die ganze Zeit
Mit OpenSUSE
QEMU ist jetzt ok das probieren wir mal aus ob das
So funktioniert
Ok keinen Schimmer wie das funktioniert
Ähm den Kram installieren
Ist schon installiert
Das ist Ubuntu gerade
Ja genau so geht das normalerweise
Kann man sich direkt connecten und gut ist
QEMU Arm QEMU
Ja das haben wir das dürften wir alles installiert haben
Wahrscheinlich geht es einfach nested
Virtualisiert nicht
QEMU System Arm Kernel
Run with Wirt Manager
What the fuck was
Was
Was ist das
Also normalerweise kann man QEMU einfach starten
Und dann bootet er halt ohne was zu machen
Reboote mal
Meinst du
Ok das habe ich echt keine Ahnung was da drinnen
Dev das ist eine gute Idee
Nein ich habe kein Dev KVM
Muss man das noch irgendwie aktivieren
KVM
Vielleicht können die das auch nicht
Was Kernel Compilen
Jetzt übertreibts mal
Übertreibts halt
KVM
Nein nein nein
Kein KVM Switch
Doch doch
Das ist nicht schwer
Ich habe da jetzt absolut keinen Bock drauf
You can do it
Was eine bescheuerte Antwort
Super
Der fragt wie mache ich das
Und der sagt You can do it
Geile Antwort
Typische Kack Forums Antwort
Ne das ist mir jetzt zu blöd
Klickt mal auf den Button im Wirtmanager
Das wird nichts bringen
Weil der Wirtmanager nicht connected ist zu KVM
Oder zu
QEMU oder was auch immer
Hopp starten
Auf gehts
Booten
Warum bootest du nicht
Gut
Chat 123
Ach ne nicht schon wieder
Ok
Also
No machine specified
Aber KVM kann das
Ne da bin ich zu low brain für
Ubuntu
Add to KVM Group
Welchen
User muss ich da
Libvirt
You need to add
Your user to Libvirt und KVM
Ich glaube nicht
Das da das klassische KVM
Drin ist
Ne das glaube ich nicht
Der Hypmode ist not available
Also bringt es auch nichts
Ne
Aber mich nervt schon mal das das
Die Kommandos annimmt zum starten
Also da mache ich irgendwas verkehrt
Also
User Mod
Was war das
User Mod minus
User Mod minus G
Minus A oder irgendwie sowas
User A ja siehste
Siehste fast fast fast richtig
Group Name also Libvirt
Wo müssen wir rein
Libvirt und KVM
Und
Machen wir einfach mal
Ne ok keine Chance
Also mit nested Virtualisierung
Das wird hier nix
No connection
Keine Chance
Was ist der Unterschied von grep zu fgrep
Ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung was fgrep macht
E-grep kann ich dir sagen
Das ist Extended Regular Expressions
Was ist denn mit ESX in ESX
Ehm
Das ist ne gute Frage ob er das supportet
Was ist
Was hast du für ein Problem
Lock dich doch ein
Ahja ok einfach refreshen
Keine Ahnung ob er das supportet ESX in ESX
Ne
Oder
Keine Ahnung ne wahrscheinlich nicht
Das wäre schon zu
Zu abgedreht irgendwie
Ich glaube mit nested Virtualization ist hier allgemein nix
Ehm
Raspien
Wir hatten auch hier vorher ein Beispiel
Drinnen
Also mit Vietmanager gehts schon mal
Also QEMU
Official Site Download
Was Download Kernel QEMU Stretch
Add
Ach du große Kacke
Was soll ich runterladen
WTF? Ok das probier wir jetzt aus
downloaden das da muss mehr das ist ja github also das da soll ich downloaden
das klappt doch im leben nicht und und was und das da
das da das da wahrscheinlich und wie startet man das ganze jetzt download
respekt schneiden wir downloaden buster kann ich auf dem 64 bit system also auf
dem 64 bit esx kann ich dann 32 bit bestimmt oder warum nicht mein runter
geht es ja geht es ja öfters aber rauf geht es halt nicht von 234
huge speed massive das krasse geschwindigkeit hier in
zeleskia china in die vm ja sieht so aus auf geht mal gas hier
das wird ja gar nichts gibt es irgendwelche mehr aus da welche mehr aus
einfach zwei mal 32 installieren für 64 bit exzellent so machen was so das haben
wir alles installiert war die die vier schritte kann ich jetzt noch machen
schau mal nach ob du eine persistent scratch lokal eine was eine was für ein
ding eine eine was will
eine was für ein ding eine eine was will
cms wim cmd okay okay habe ich weiß nicht was es ist aber habe ich anscheinend
also kommt lad gibt gas gib gas download das liegt nicht an einem
raspberry pi das liegt ziemlich sicher an dem an dem mirror von von von
respekt oder von rest bs heißt jetzt ja ich habe übelst hunger leute wisst ihr das
das machen wir jetzt noch und dann gehe ich was essen wie lange sind wir schon am
start über vier stunden habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt dass das so lange
gedauert hat allein schon die installation hat zwei stunden gedauert
du kannst die ssh warnung ausschalten sehr gut war gleich das erinnert mich ein
bisschen an die windows registry wenn ich solche dinge hier sehen auf laden
runter machen
so langsam auch wenn ich das von hier mache
oh nein warum ist kann das sein dass das netzwerk in der ubuntu vm abartig langsam
ist
nun mal so das ist ja montag ist langsam also monka giga es langsam ich habe kein
lg tv ich habe einen sony fernseher mit android tv drauf aber das verwende ich
nicht ich verwende nur
das Shield-TV dran. Das ging jetzt aber doch schon ein bisschen schneller als
gedacht habe. SCP Raspberry Links OS. Da kopiere ich so rüber, das scheint ja
schneller zu gehen. Lull! Guck mal, der Download da oben ist nicht mehr
ansatzweise fertig und hier flutscht es mit 30 MB die Sekunde rüber. Alles klar.
Zack. Deleted. Home. Max. Und jetzt rüber kopieren. Zack. Sehr gut. So und jetzt
müssen wir was machen? Unzip. Unzip. Raspberry. Achso. Unzip mal.
QEMO Image Convert. Haben wir eigentlich jetzt, wenn wir uns auf das Ubuntu
verbinden. Da können wir mal einen Hardtop oder so was drauf machen,
dass wir ein bisschen mehr...
Ein bisschen gucken können, wie ausgelastet... Ich meine, das hat ein Kern. Und für einen
CPU-Kern, muss ich echt sagen, läuft diese Ubuntu-Sache erstaunlich gut.
Hardtop T-Mark Swim. So, erstmal die ordentlichen Sachen installieren.
Oh, ich glaube, ich installiere hier nichts in der Zeit, wo der da oben
entpackt. Hat Unzip so was wie eine Progress-Anzeige? Progress? What?
Was ist das? Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das hier macht. Warum das überhaupt funktioniert. Aber es ist eh fertig. Wie, alle schon installiert? Wie das kommt? Die kommen voll installiert mit einem Hardtop. Alter, Ubuntu ist ja mal hier Next Level mittlerweile. Resize. Okay, was auch immer jetzt hier ist. Moment, habe ich das da oben schon gemacht? Ne, das habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Äh, Raspbian.
Latest Image.
To, was weiß ich, bei irgendwas.
Matt, das habe ich falsch gemacht.
Ach, hier.
Die Hackermans sind wieder da.
Also, heute ist ja mal wirklich
Massive Hackermans-Stream.
Boah, ist das langsam.
Alter, das kackt ja mal richtig ab.
Ich glaube, der Raspberry Pi brennt sich gleich durch.
Und warum startet
er 8 Threads oder sowas?
Übertreibt's halt.
Oh, wollen wir den Raspberry Pi gleich nochmal übertakten und gucken, ob er dann komplett anfängt zu glühen?
Ne, wollen wir nicht.
Der, der taktet sich jetzt garantiert schon runter.
Ich könnte wetten, dass er sich jetzt schon runter taktet.
So, dann machen wir das. Das geht schnell. Und dann können wir die VM starten und gucken, ob es geht.
Und gucken, ob es geht.
Und wahrscheinlich werden wir dann feststellen, es geht gar nicht, weil Nested Virtualization nicht unterstützt wird.
Auf, mach hin.
Puemo Convert.
Was heute am Start? Wir haben ESX installiert auf Raspberry Pi.
Excellent. Guck hier. Da läuft er.
On Arm Fling.
Image Resized.
Achtung, jetzt geht's los hier.
Zack. Bam.
So, wir müssen aber noch was...
Oh, ne. Ah, fuck.
Ah, was ein Müll.
Ich hab vergessen, wie man Command Mode in Vim macht.
So.
Äh...
Ich muss hier nämlich noch ein bisschen was ändern.
Ich muss hier das Image eintragen.
Und ich muss hier die...
...das da eintragen.
Und als Kernel...
...kommt das andere, was wir runtergeladen haben.
Kernel.
Bam. Ja.
Moment.
GTK Initialization Fail.
Das ist was anderes.
Der hat andere Schmerzen hier gerade.
Hier, X, X Connection Rejected.
Okay, der hat probiert zu starten.
Moment, wie ging das jetzt nochmal mit dem X Zeugs weiterleiten?
Äh, Cat.
Das da.
Und jetzt X, X...
So, ne?
Aha. Achso.
Ha?
Postchamp? Vm?
Vm in Vm.
Pogo.
Okay, das ist jetzt echt abgedrehter Shit.
Es ist absolut sinnlos.
Er ist übrigens auch gerade voll am verrecken, glaube ich.
Oder auch nicht.
Startet der? Ne, der crasht gerade, oder?
Oh, Kernel Panic. Oh, ne.
Er bootet nicht.
Kernel Panic.
Er mag nicht.
Ja, gut. Da werden wir jetzt nichts zu machen können.
Da werden wir jetzt nichts zu machen können.
Kernel Panic.
Achso, vielleicht soll ich mal QEMO System...
...A64...
...dann kann ich das richtig machen.
Ah, Postchamp, Postchamp.
Oh, ne. Kernel Crash.
Okay, also...
...prinzipiell...
...würde es funktionieren.
Allerdings...
...realistisch betrachtet eher nicht.
Also, theoretisch kann man Nested virtualisieren.
Aber praktisch gesehen wird es, glaube ich,
eher...
...nix.
Aber trotzdem, cooler Versuch,
dass das funktioniert hat.
Nice.
Vielleicht reicht auch das Memory nicht.
Memory 512.
Oh.
Memory must not exceed.
But why?
Na gut.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Schön, dass so viele Leute wieder mit dabei gewesen sind.
Bin ja immer wieder begeistert,
dass wir hier Andi oder teilweise zwischendurch mal
kurzzeitig über 200 Leute haben,
die sich angucken, wie ich mit dem ESX
auf nem Raspberry Pi rumwurste.
Sehr nice.
Wir gucken mal, ob der Frasier
on ist oder der mCore.
Nein, der Frasier ist nicht on.
Ist der mCore on?
Ich hoste mir den Jan.
Nein, der ist auch nicht da.
Sein Logo ist übrigens kaputt seitdem er sich umbenannt hat.
Na gut.
Wir sehen uns in einem
der nächsten Streams wieder.
Macht's gut. Bis denn.
Leute, CU.